monsieur le président directeur général
mes chers collègues notre commission a
débuté hier un cycle d'auditions visant
d'une part à poser le diagnostic sur les
raisons ayant conduit à l'arrêt de plus
de la moitié des réacteurs du parc
nucléaire sur les responsabilités en ce
domaine et sur les moyens de relancer au
plus vite la production et ceux ci que
d'audition doit donner l'occasion d'une
part d'autre part pardon de d'étudier
les scénarios de consommation et de
production y compris les plus sombres
des mois à venir et d'élaborer des
solutions concrètes pour que
collectivement nous puissions surmonter
l'épreuve énergétique monsieur le
président
l'entreprise que vous dirigez est au
coeur de multiples interrogations notre
pays est confronté pour l'hiver à venir
à un problème d'offre énergétique ce
problème résultent de causes multiples
et variés pour certaines comme la
réduction drastique des livraisons de
gaz russe ou encore le faible niveau des
réservoirs des barrages hydroélectriques
du fait de la sécheresse edf ne fait que
subir la situation en revanche pour ce
qui concerne spécifiquement le sujet de
l'offre en électricité la crise est
amplement aggravées du fait de
l'indisponibilité actuel de 32 réacteurs
de notre parc nucléaire sur un total de
56 la responsabilité d'edf à ce niveau
peut donc être interrogé mais bien
évidemment ces interrogations ne vise
pas l'ensemble des équipes des agents
d'edf dont nous connaissons tous
l'application et dévouement quotidien
sur le terrain
puisque j'ai évoqué au début de mon
intervention la nécessité d'un
diagnostic je souhaiterais que nos
actions cette audition sur les raisons
justifiant l'arrêt de ses réacteurs en
détaillant la nature de problème le
nombre de réacteurs concernés en tant
qu'élus nous sommes tous fréquemment
interrogé par les citoyens de nos
circonscriptions qui voudraient
comprendre comprendre pourquoi autant de
réacteurs sont indisponibles savoir
quand est ce qu'ils vont fonctionner à
nouveau et si de nouvelles difficultés
peuvent éventuellement apparaître les
travaux de maintenance ou de
rechargement ou les interventions
nécessaires pour envisager le
prolongement pour envisager de prolonger
la durée de vie d'un réacteur sont
compréhensibles à condition que la jeune
daffix et même après les perturbations
induites par la crise sanitaire
apparaissent rationnel on peut être un
peu plus dubitatif pour ce qui concerne
les arrêts de réacteurs liés aux
problèmes dits de corrosion
contrainte comment de telles difficultés
ont-elles pu survenir sont pas liés à
des pertes de compétences à des défauts
d'investissement à des défaillances dans
la surveillance de la sécurité nucléaire
aurait-elle pu être prise en compte plus
tôt en étalant dans le temps les
réparations pour préserver le nombre de
réacteurs en fonctionnement serez vous
en mesure de redémarrer tous ses
réacteurs pour l'hiver et quel sera le
nombre de réacteurs que vous devrez
malgré tout que vous serez dans
l'obligation de stopper dans le cadre
des procédures normales de maintenance
au final la production du parc nucléaire
cet hiver cet hiver sera t elle
suffisante pour faire face aux pics de
consommation
les interrogations sur les compétences
d'edf se pose d'autant plus que
l'entreprise a le plus grand mal depuis
plusieurs années achever la construction
et la mise en service des ep r que ce
soit celui de flamanville où ceux de
finlande ou du royaume uni j'observe
d'ailleurs que le canard enchaîné de ce
jour fait état d'une anomalie de
conception sur la cuve de flamanville
pourriez-vous nous fournir quelques
explications à ce sujet dans ces
conditions un programme de construction
de nouveaux repères pour permettre au
pays de faire face à la hausse de
consommation d'électricité anticipé par
rte à l'horizon 2040-2050 peut-il être
envisager sereinement les difficultés et
les défis qu edf doit affronter à court
moyen et long terme évidemment un coût
financier immense alors même que vos
recettes sont contraintes par le
mécanisme de la reine ce qui conduit les
pouvoirs publics depuis un certain temps
à s'interroger sur la structure de la
gouvernance de votre entreprise et a
déjà amené l'état a souhaité porter sa
participation à 100% du capital ce sujet
n'est pas au coeur de l'audition
d'aujourd'hui encore une fois cette
audition est axée sur les capacités de
production mais je l'évoquent néanmoins
car notre commission sera probablement
amenée à travailler prochainement sur
ces questions monsieur le président
directeur général je vous cède la parole
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
tout d'abord vous dire que je suis très
heureux d'être avec vous mesdames et
messieurs les députés les membres de
cette commission et avec vous monsieur
le président et avec quelques
collaborateurs qui sont là vous dire
combien nous sommes attachés à partager
les informations avec la représentation
nationale à vous deux et vous comme au
public en général un maximum
d'informations et à reconnaître que ces
informations sont souvent un peu
technique un peu un peu complexe un peu
contrainte par des réglementations
multiples bien évidemment qui s'attache
à une entreprise comme edf c'est une
entreprise c'est une entreprise cotée
elle répond à un grand nombre de
directives et de et de loi dans le cadre
de l'union européenne et de la
république bien sûr nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un contexte complexe
difficile et je voudrais peut-être
commencer mon propos
par revenir en quelques mots sur la
crise que nous vivons c'est une crise
énergétique majeure
beaucoup disent je crois que c'est vrai
qu'elle est d'une ampleur similaire ou
chocs pétroliers des années 70 ce messie
ici ce dont nous parlons c'est d'un choc
gazier d'un double choc et gazier le
premier choc gazier qui est vraiment un
choc donc leur mondial il remonte à 2021
et chacun s'accorde à penser qu'il est
causé principalement par l'ampleur de la
reprise économique à la fin de la crise
qu vide qui s'est traduite par une forte
hausse du prix du gaz en asie et en
europe une concurrence entre l'asie et
l'europe pour faire venir le gaz vers
une production industrielle qui
redécolle et de ce fait une première
hausse du prix de l'électricité sur les
marchés de gros européen l'un des
graphiques que l'on vous a distribué je
crois vous montre bien cette hausse
vertigineuse et donc dès 2021 cette
première crise conduit les pouvoirs
publics français à prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles de nature fiscale et
réglementaire c'est ce qu'on appelle le
bouclier tarifaires et ceci intervient
avant tout la détection de corrosion
sous contrainte bien évidemment elle et
elle est postérieure elle date des tout
derniers jours de 2021 et puis nous
avons un second choc gazier qui est
cette fois ci plutôt un choc qui touche
l'europe ou principalement l'europe ce
sont les conséquences de la guerre en
ukraine à partir de février 2022 une
nouvelle envolée des prix du gaz mais
aussi une crise de sécurité
d'approvisionnement énergétique due à
l'arrêt progressif de l'alimentation de
l'europe en gaz russe aujourd'hui cette
crise se poursuit elle déstabilise
profondément je vais y revenir les
systèmes européens gaziers et
électriques qui sont interdépendants
bien évidemment cette tension a des
répercussions sur les prix de l'énergie
et je vais évidemment centre et mon
propos sur les prix de l'électricité
mais je voudrais souligner qu'elle a
aussi des conséquences sur l'ensemble de
l'économie et sur les perspectives
d'inflation et donc à la fin de mon
propos introductif je vous présenterai
rapidement nos actions pour accompagner
nos clients dans ce contexte
premièrement les faits sur le prix de
l'électricité
la première hausse des prix du gaz celle
du 2ème semestre 2021 a entraîné
mécaniquement une hausse des prix de
l'électricité partout en europe comme
vous le savez le mécanisme de formation
des prix de l'électricité sur le marché
de gros reflètent les coûts de
production des dernières centrales
électriques appelés pour répondre à la
demande et quand le prix du gaz est
élevé ces dernières centrales sont bien
sûr des centrales au gaz ce mécanisme
qui conduit à faire supporter aux
consommateurs d'électricité français la
volatilité des prix du gaz c'est
incohérent sur le plan climatique et
économique le gouvernement et edf ont
relevé ce point il ya déjà plusieurs
mois il ya aujourd'hui des discussions
pour une réforme de ce marché
la hausse de 2021 sur les marchés de
gros de l'électricité a été suffisamment
forte pour justifier une première série
de mesures prises par les gouvernements
en europe pour en atténuer les effets
sur les différentes catégories de
consommateurs c'est ainsi qu'en france
le parlement a voté en 2021 une baisse
de la fiscalité sur l'électricité c'est
la taxe dite tei cfe qui est passée de
22,5 euros du mégawattheure à 0.5 la
presse qui était supprimée mais pas tout
à fait et puis a également été mis en
place un dispositif de boucliers
tarifaire pour limiter l'évolution des
tarifs régulés pour les particuliers à
4% c'est la dernière augmentation de ce
tarif qui a eu lieu en février 2022 en
janvier 2022 de plus le gouvernement a
pris la décision d'augmenter de manière
exceptionnelle
le volume annuel de la reine de 100
térawattheures à 120 térawattheures
depuis février 2022 à la suite de
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
nous subissons un deuxième choc de prix
sur le gaz qui accentue la hausse des
prix du gaz et qui par conséquent se
reflète là aussi sur l'électricité sur
le marché de gros de l'électricité dans
les deux cas comme vous le montre le
graphique l'évolution du prix de
l'électricité est directement corrélé au
prix du gaz
quelques mots sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
la réduction puis l'arrêt progressif des
livraisons de gaz par la russie d'abord
à certains pays d'europe orientale et
puis plus récemment de fait par l'arrêt
de nord stream 1 à l'allemagne et et à
toute l'europe occidentale
cela présente un risque
d'approvisionnement pour toutes les
catégories de consommateurs les
consommateurs domestiques les
consommateurs industriels et aussi pour
la production d'électricité
en utilisant le gaz naturel comme
combustible
cette production d'électricité à partir
de gaz représente 12% de la production
d'allemagne 18 % en moyenne pour l'union
européenne en 2020 mais en france nous
sommes plus près plus protégés parce que
nous dépendons - au gaz et en
particulier au gaz russe pour produire
de l'électricité
il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui la première
et principale menace sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'europe ce sont ces phénomènes sur le
marché gazier je les dis la production
d'électricité à partir de gaz naturel en
france
représente en volume une part limitée
mais elle est essentielle à certains
moments à l'équilibrage général ces
moments ce sont les périodes de pointe
nous avons besoin de ces centrales au
gaz de même que nous avons besoin de la
production hydroélectrique
or la sécheresse de cette année 2022
nous conduit à adopter depuis le
printemps dernier une gestion très
prudente de loki et non aux barrages
parce qu'il faut que ces barrages puisse
contribuer au passage des pointes de
consommation tout au long de l'hiver
d'autant que la production d'électricité
à partir de gaz naturel pourrait se
trouver en concurrence avec d'autres
usages dustrit yale de ce gaz devenu un
bien rare vous même le parlement vous
avez voté cet été la possibilité qu'a
désormais l'état de reprendre
directement en main la gestion des
centrales électriques au gaz des
différents opérateurs dont edf
j'en reviens au parc nucléaire cette
crise intervient à un moment où notre
parc nucléaire conduite un programme
essentiel de modernisation
il a été programmé de longue date et le
grand carénage de notre parc de
centrales est un investissement majeur
il va permettre dans une première étape
de poursuivre au delà de 40 ans
l'exploitation de nos trente deux
réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
mais en contrepartie de ces travaux les
arrêts des réacteurs sont plus longs ils
sont plus long lors des visites
décennales à 40 ans que nous appelons
les bd 4 900 parce que le volume de
travaux de ces quatrième visite
décennale est cinq fois supérieur au
volume de travaux lors des troisièmes
visites décennales
pourquoi parce que c'est évident et 4
intègre le solde des travaux dits post
fukushima qui permettent de renforcer le
niveau de sûreté de nos installations
c'est en 2019 qu'ont débuté cdd 4 sur le
réacteurs de tricastin 1 dans la vallée
du rhône cdd cac se poursuivre
aujourd'hui sur d'autres réacteurs du
palier 900 mégawatts sur les 32
réacteurs qui doivent
faire l'objet de ces travaux cette
visite décennale sont terminées
aujourd'hui
depuis longtemps nous savons que le
rythme entre 2021 et 2025 va être très
élevé avec en moyenne cinq visites
décennales de ce type par an sur cette
période du fait du volume des travaux
dont j'ai parlé ces arrêts à 40 ans sont
de longue durée sur les 7 premiers
arrêts qui sont terminées le réacteur
s'arrête 240 214 jours 214 jours alors
que c'était en moyenne 164 jours pour
les arrêts à 30 ans et comme il ya cinq
des d4 en moyenne par an cela revient
chaque année à effacer la production
annuelle d'un réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
cela nous le savons de longue date et
donc de longue date nous nous sommes
préparés à ce grand carénage nous nous
sommes préparés par des embauches très
importante chaque année entre 2011 et
2014 sur le périmètre production et
ingénierie nucléaire edf à embaucher
environ 2000 personnes pour un flux
annuel de départ en retraite d'environ
1000 personnes deux mille embauches 1000
départs en retraite nous avons ainsi en
anticipation
constitué des pépinières c'est comme ça
que nous les appelons ces pépinières
avait pour objectif de former des
salariés en les mettant en compagnonnage
avec un collègue plus expérimentés de
telle sorte que ces jeunes puissent
acquérir les compétences nécessaires
afin de pouvoir ensuite réaliser les
activités en étant dûment habilités et
finalement prendre le relais des plus
anciens au moment de leur départ en
retraite
nous avons aussi donné ici en salle la
courbe des embauches et des départs en
retraite qui illustre cela et vous
verrez que sur les années suivantes
jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous avons quasiment
intégralement compenser chaque année les
départs en retraite par des embauches et
donc nous avons bien constitué pour le
grand carénage un vivier de personnel
supplémentaire qualifier
j'ai été nommé fin 2014 en janvier 2015
lors du conseil d'administration le
premier après ma nomination j'ai fait
adopter par le conseil d'administration
le grand carénage et j'ai fait voter le
budget du grand carénage pour la période
2014-2020 tu 5 nous avons ensuite
modifier notre organisation en créant
une direction dédiée à ce projet de
grande ampleur cette direction est
chargée d'anticiper et surtout de mettre
en ordre de marche toutes les parties
prenantes l'exploitation la gêne gris et
puis bien sûr tous nos partenaires de la
filière industrie industriels nous avons
régulièrement communiqué sur
l'avancement du grand carénage et nous
considérons que ce programme est un
succès
entre 2015 et 2018 la filière nucléaire
edf et ses partenaires industriels
nous avons ensemble recruter trente
mille personnes cette hausse témoigne de
la continuité d'une dynamique de
recrutement dans la filière alors même
que l'activité générée par le chantier
de l'epr de flamanville 3 était en
baisse d'intensité et qu'il n'existait
alors aucun chantier de construction
neuve d'ampleur en perspective en france
au moment où le grand carénage ces
derniers mois entrait dans son pic
d'activité
nous avons dû nous avons dû faire face à
deux difficultés totalement imprévisible
le coc vide et la corrosion sous
contrainte quelques mots sur le col vide
vous vous souvenez
le coc vide a imposé un réaménagement
profond de toute l'économie française de
toute l'industrie française et d'edf est
donc un réaménagement profond des arrêts
de tranche à cause des confinement qui
avait conduit à la fermeture des
frontières à l'as disponibilité des
entreprises et aussi des travailleurs
notamment ceux qui se déplacent de site
en site pour les chantiers
n'oublions pas que pendant le premier
confinement edf a bien sûr maintenu le
fonctionnement du parc nucléaire et a
garanti l'alimentation électrique du
pays en toute sûreté mais aussi pendant
ce premier confinement tous les
chantiers se sont arrêtés
or les travaux de maintenance du parc
nucléaire nécessite un réglage fin
permanent avec une planification très
précise des travaux de maintenance de
manière à ce que chaque hiver nous
disposions d'un maximum de productions
la crise du coc vide nous a conduits dès
2020 à réorganiser tout le programme
d'arrêt de tranche pour les années
suivantes d'abord pour sécuriser le
passage de l'hiver 2020-2021 ce qui a
été fait mais aussi pour tenir compte de
tout cela sur la vie des du parc pendant
les deux hivers suivants puisque nous
avons subi nous subissons encore
aujourd'hui des conséquences en chaîne
suite à la réorganisation de notre
programme de travaux nés de cette
interruption de tous nos chantiers
pendant le confinement
deuxièmement il vous m'interpeller là
dessus monsieur le président la
corrosion sous contrainte la corrosion
sous contrainte est un phénomène
totalement inattendu qui a été détecté
en décembre
2021 au moment d'un contrôle au moment
d'une visite décennale sur un réacteur à
ses récents celui de si vos seins et
nous avons détecté un endommagement il
très inattendu de l'acier du circuit
d'injection de sécurité donc à proximité
de la cub
de ce fait nous avons engagé des
contrôles sur des réacteurs similaires
et nous nous sommes aperçus que la
sûreté avant tout nous devions mettre
rapidement à l'arrêt non seulement le
réacteur 2 6 juin mais les trois autres
réacteurs du palier n4 dont il se trouve
que c'est le palier le plus récent du
parc
ce phénomène inattendu nous a amené à
définir un ensemble de contrôles des
expertises d' analyse de façon à
comprendre quelle est la nature du
phénomène quels sont les réacteurs les
plus sensibles à l'apparition de ce
phénomène
d'identifier dans quelle zone du
réacteur le phénomène est en mesure de
se manifester
et puis d'amener un programme de
contrôle susceptible de toucher
l'ensemble du parc nous avons donc mené
tout au long du premier semestre
une analyse très complète qui nous a
amenés à proposer à l'asn à la fin du
printemps au milieu du printemps une
stratégie pour traiter ce sujet de la
corrosion sous contrainte
fin juillet fin juillet 2022 l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire a jugé la stratégie
d'edf approprié
l'apparition de la corrosion sous
contrainte sur ses tuyauteries du
circuit d'injection de sécurité bien sûr
était totalement inattendu pour pour
tous les experts nous en avons
aujourd'hui une meilleure compréhension
à la fois en termes d'apparitions et de
conséquences nous avons aussi au cours
de ces six mois développer un nouveau à
nouveau moyen de contrôler un moyen de
contrôle non destructif qui nous
permettent d'éviter d'avoir à couper des
tuyauteries pour aller regarder ce qui
se passe dedans nous avons donc là aussi
innover et nous avons aujourd'hui la
possibilité de poursuivre avec plus
d'efficacité moins d'interruptions le
diagnostic de nos réacteurs le programme
de contrôle lui-même a reçu
l'approbation d'autorités de tu es
nucléaire là aussi fin juillet nos
équipes et celles de nos partenaires
industriels sont pleinement mobilisés
pour effectuer les travaux de réparation
qui sont en cours et pour remettre sur
le réseau le maximum de réacteurs
possible pour le prochain hiver
bien sûr ces travaux de réparation
viennent accroître la charge de travail
programmé pour le grand carénage il se
pose le sujet du degré de préparation de
la filière nucléaire pour surmonter la
crise que nous traversons cette question
ce sujet m'amène à préciser certains de
mes propos récents
je viens de vous l'indiquer nous faisons
face à un cumul inattendu d'activité qui
mobilise des compétences pointues et
rares notamment celle de tuyauteur et de
soudeur mais aussi de robin étiez du
zinner de chaudronnier et d'autres
professions ce déficit de compétences
affecte notre capacité à réparer au
rythme que nous souhaiterions
je me permets de revenir dix ans en
arrière
le débat sur le rôle du nucléaire en
france s'est intensifié après l'accident
de fukushima qui date de mars 2011 est
aussi dans le contexte des décisions
politiques de 2012 tout cela a perturbé
la filière beaucoup en france à
l'étranger on parlait d'un hiver
nucléaire pendant ces années post
fukushima et nous n'avons regagné en
visibilité que très progressivement j'en
ai parlé la validation du programme de
grand carénage tout début d'année tout
début 2015 nous a permis d'organiser
avec succès la montée en charge de la
filière nucléaire pour faire face aux
programmes de maintenance du parc
nucléaire la maintenance courante celle
que nous effectuerons depuis toujours
comme la maintenance lourde ce grand
carénage qui vient s'ajouter à la
maintenance courante
le report de 2025 à 2035 de la date à
laquelle la part du nucléaire dans la
production d'électricité
devrait atteindre l'objectif de 50% ce
report a été rendue publique il ya cinq
ans on février 2021 avec la vie
générique qu'elle a publiés l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire a approuvé le
référentiel technique pour
l'exploitation des centrales nucléaires
du palier 900 mégawatts au delà de 40
ans et plus récemment février 2002 le
discours de belfort a clairement posé le
cadre de développement du nucléaire en
france à moyen et long terme tant pour
le parc actuel que pour la construction
de nouvelles unités
avec cette visibilité qui s'améliore
progressivement nous sommes en mesure de
poursuivre la montée en charge de la
filière au cours des prochaines années
nous allons notamment nous appuyer sur
l'université des métiers du nucléaire
que la filière a lancé en étroite
coordination avec le gouvernement et en
application du plan excellent que j'ai
décidé fin 2019 je voudrais vous donner
un exemple nous avons lancé une école de
soudage nous l'avons créée dans le
cotentin elle commence tout juste à
mettre à la disposition des entreprises
ces premières promotions de soudeur
spécialisé nucléaire
mais dans la situation exceptionnelle
que nous vivons avec la corrosion sous
contrainte et les effets du co vide qui
viennent s'ajouter aux très gros
programme de maintenance lourde qu'est
le grand carénage je dois vous dire que
nous n'avons pas de soudeur ou tuyauteur
qualifiés supplémentaires que nous
pourrions déplacer en nombre d' un
chantier de construction pour mettre ces
personnes d'urgence sur la réparation du
parc existant c'est pour ça que je
parlais des difficultés à soutenir le
rythme que nous aimerions auquel nous
aimerions pouvoir réparer les réacteurs
de ce fait nous faisons appel à des
soudeurs qui viennent d'autres pays je
dois dire que si il y a dix ans par
exemple la filière nucléaire avait pu
lancer deux ou trois chantiers de
construction de nouveaux réacteurs nous
aurions aujourd'hui dix ans plus tard
plus de salariés qualifiés dans un
ensemble de métiers spécialisés et ses
salariés qualifiés nous aurions pu
momentanément pour quelques mois les
déplacés des chantiers de construction
vers les chantiers du parc actuel qui
sont si urgent
voilà ces précisions j'y tiens me
permettent d'expliquer l'absence de
marge de manoeuvre de la filière pour
absorber cette fluctuation brutale et
inattendue de charges en particulier là
où les compétences sont les plus
pointues
nous avons su préserver l'essentiel
grâce à l'activité de maintenance
courante grâce aux 4 grand carénage en
france et aussi il faut le dire grâce à
la construction qui est en cours des
deux réacteurs br dink les poètes en
grande bretagne la dynamique positive
elle est ré enclenché en particulier
avec le discours de belfort mais tout
cela prend du temps c'est le temps
industriels
la mobilisation des hommes et des femmes
d'edf et de tous les acteurs de la
filière pour aller au plus vite cette
mobilisation est totale
à ce jour nous avons 27 réacteurs
connectés au réseau électrique
trois autres réacteurs sont placés en
situation d'économie de combustible ces
trois réacteurs volontairement nous leur
faisons pas produire d'électricité en ce
moment de manière à ce qu'il soit
disponible pour produire pendant l'hiver
prochain
nous avons donc 27 +3 30 réacteurs
disponibles et 26 en arrêt les raisons
de ces arrêts sont les suivantes dix
réacteurs sont en arrêt programmé pour
les maintenance classique
dix réacteurs font l'objet de
réparations dans le cadre du dossier de
la corrosion sous contrainte cinq
réacteurs font l'objet de contrôles de
recherche de corrosion sous contrainte
sur ses tuyauteries enfin nous avons un
réacteur en arrêt fortuit ce sont des
généralement des arrêts de courte durée
concernant les chantiers de réparation
des réacteurs sur lesquels nous avons de
la corrosion sous contrainte ces
chantiers ont commencé cet été ils
avancent à bon rythme je voudrais vous
dire et nous en sommes fiers que nous
avons déjà terminé le premier de ces
chantiers le chantier de tricastin 3 est
terminée sur si vos seins qui est un des
chantiers les plus lourds à réaliser
nous avons déjà effectué plus de 50 %
des travaux
là je voudrais terminer ce propos
liminaire en vous parlant de nos de nos
clients nous sommes bien sûr très
mobilisés sur toutes les dimensions de
la crise pour retrouver des marges de
manoeuvre et je vous ai parlé de
production je voudrais vous parler un
petit peu aussi de la demande nous
accompagnons tous nos clients les
ménages des entreprises et les
collectivités
en tant que fournisseur responsable
d'électricité mais aussi plus largement
d'énergie et de services vous le savez
ce sens des responsabilités et du
service public c'est l'adn d'edf depuis
sa création ces valeurs à nîmes l'action
et l'engagement de tous nos salariés au
quotidien
nos clients reconnaissent les expertises
le sérieux d'edf nous suivons
attentivement des indicateurs de
confiance les indicateurs de confiance
de nos clients comme d'ailleurs de nos
salariés sont à des niveaux très élevés
même quand on les compare aux meilleures
entreprises au delà du secteur de
l'énergie
depuis des années et ceci bien avant la
crise que nous traversons aujourd'hui
nous proposons une large gamme d'offres
pour aider nos clients à consommer moins
et à consommer mieux à ce titre les
appelle à la sobriété électrique et
énergétique sous-tend nos actions depuis
longtemps quelques exemples d'abord pour
les ménages les clients résidentiels
grâce à nos conseillers basés en france
et à nos outils tels que l'application
edf et moi nos clients bénéficient déjà
de conseils personnalisés
ceux de nos clients qui utilisent edf et
moi peuvent réduire leur consommation
d'électricité de plus de 10% c'est un
chiffre qui a été attestée par des tiers
je rappelle également que nous sommes le
seul fournisseur d'électricité à
maintenir hiver comme été une
alimentation minimale d'électricité en
cas d'impayés
en coordination avec les démarches
engagées par le gouvernement nous allons
lancer en octobre les campagnes de
communication et de sensibilisation de
grande ampleur de façon à chaque à ce
que chacun de nos concitoyens puissent
s'inscrire dans une logique vertueuse de
sobriété en s'appuyant notamment sur des
écogestes
le signal tarifaire est également un
levier important pour encourager les
économies d'énergie
l'option heures pleines heures creuses
et déjà très largement répandue c'est
une donnée de base de notre secteur elle
couvre 10 millions de nos clients en
octobre nous allons promouvoir l'option
qui s'appelle tempo pour ceux de nos
clients qui sont aux tarifs régulés le
trv nous avons obtenu l'autorisation de
promouvoir désormais cette option auprès
de nos clients nous espérons une
souscription importante
s'agissant des entreprises et des
collectivités
en matière de maîtrise de la demande et
d'efficacité d'énergétique
nous nous appuyons sur edf est aussi sur
notre filiale dalkia pour déployer de
nombreuses offres et de nombreux
services les contrats de performance
énergétique dans lequel nous nous
engageons contractuellement en matière
de réduction de la consommation
le développement le plus rapide possible
de réseaux de chaleur et de froid qui
permet aux collectivités de réduire
l'exposition des clients de ses réseaux
au prix de l'énergie et lorsque la
chaleur et le froid sont produira sont
produits à partir d'énergies
renouvelables
cela contribue aussi à la décarbonation
de l'économie par ailleurs nous
accompagnons chacun de nos clients
entreprises et collectivités
avec des offres adaptées à leurs besoins
qui leur permettent de baisser voire de
reporter leur consommation un mot
là-dessus
chaque année en particulier pendant
l'hiver nous signons des contrats de
capacités d'effacement avec certains
clients industriels ses clients
perçoivent une rémunération
lorsqu ils suspendent leur consommation
lors de périodes de tension du réseau
électrique cela existe depuis longtemps
et contribuer au passage des heures de
pointe nous l'avons donc fait avec
succès les hivers passés nous allons
renforcer cette démarche pour l'hiver à
venir
pour l'hiver à venir nous pensons donc
que ces actions que je viens de vous
résumer qui ce qu'on peut appeler des
accents d'effacement ou de modulation
volontaire de la consommation cela
représente un gisement additionnelles
que nous estimons à un gigawatt environ
dont plusieurs centaines de mètres hawat
pour les clients résidentiels haute et
hervé qui se mettront sur l'option tempo
voilà pour conclure je vous dirais que
les circonstances exceptionnelles que
nous le connaissons en ce moment exige
toutes ces actions urgentes elles
s'inscrivent dans une démarche de long
terme que nous ne perdons pas de vue
l'urgence climatique nécessite d'asand
d'accentuer encore plus nos efforts en
faveur de la transition énergétique et
de la décarbonation nos usages c'est
notre raison d'être et chez edf nous
oeuvrons chaque jour en ce sens je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président directeur
général pour ses propos je vais donc
maintenant passer la parole aux
différents orateurs des groupes chez
monsieur me dit madame la porte monsieur
tavel monsieur vigier monsieur daubié
adam battistel madame l'air nous
monsieur jumelles et madame bassir
monsieur midi pour le comprenez sens
c'est à vous alors je précise juste
avant que vous démarriez le jeu rappelle
le fonctionnement comme je le fais à
chaque fois quatre minutes
inclus votre réponse monsieur le
président directeur général et donc vous
avez le chrono qui est juste ici et je
me permettrai de couper ou de vous
inviter à couper dès qu'on arrive à 4
minutes mais je me dis c'est à vous
non ça y est ça marche pardon merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président directeur général chers
collègues alors merci pour votre exposé
je pense qu'ils étaient effectivement
très claires sur les raisons dans
lesquelles on se trouve qu'ils
expliquent la situation vaut
clarification aussi sur un centre de vos
propos qui parfois ont pu être peut-être
mal interprétés mais avant de revenir
sur cette situation je voudrais faire un
petit rappel de contexte parce que dans
cette enceinte nous avons des
parlementaires qui d'un côté de la salle
pense que les énergies renouvelables
sont parfois inutiles inefficaces qu'il
faudrait rapidement démontés les
éoliennes par exemple et de l'autre côté
de la salle des parlementaires qui
considère que le nucléaire est trop
dangereux pour être une solution et que
tous les réacteurs dont vous avez parlé
il faudrait les les éteindre et se
passer de cette énergie nous notre
stratégie avec le président de la
république le gouvernement et la
majorité présidentielle elle est très
claire elle n'a pas bougé depuis que
notre formation politique existe et elle
repose sur deux jambes la première jambe
c'est l'énergie nucléaire la deuxième
jambe ce sont les énergies renouvelables
l'énergie renouveler les rejets
nucléaires il faut la développer ce sont
six pères qui ont été lancés et 8 qui
sont en projet sur les énergies
renouvelables
ce sont un objectif très clair de 2 x 10
l'énergie solaire les 50 parc éolien
offshore a développé et puis devenir les
l'hydrogène les leaders de l'hydrogène
vert en europe alors cette crise de
l'énergie que nous vivons qui est
conjoncturelle vous l'avez rappelé elle
vient à la fois de la reprise économique
posco vide de la guerre en ukraine mais
aussi du fait pour la situation
particulière de la france que nous avons
une trentaine les chiffres varient
parfois de réacteurs qui sont à l'arrêt
principalement pour cause de maintenance
si nous n'avions pas ces réacteurs à
l'arrêt nous n'aurions pas de problème
pour cet hiver et nous aurions même pu
même peut-être pas ce débat aujourd'hui
et comme il est plus facile de remettre
en marche des réacteurs nucléaires que
d'arrêter la guerre en ukraine d'ici
l'hiver c'est à edf qu'il incombe de
remettre en marche ses réacteurs et
c'est d'ailleurs l'occasion d'illustrer
l'excellence de nos ingénieurs français
dont beaucoup viennent de ma
circonscription à paris saclay je les ai
j'en profite pour les saluer vous avez
bien expliquer pourquoi nous nous
retrouverons dans cette situation est-ce
que vous pouvez nous exposer quel est le
plan pour les mois prochains
quel réacteur combien vont être réouvert
dans quel calendrier et avec quelle
probabilité évidemment de réouverture
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
président directeur général
ah pardon merci pour le micro je vais
j'ai passé la parole à à cédric
lewandowski directeur exécutif du parc
nucléaire et thermique mais je voudrais
peut-être en un mot parce que j'entends
les mots de transparence et quel
réacteur nous avons une règle
européenne une directive européenne qui
s'appellerait mythe qui nous impose de
mettre sur notre site la totalité des
informations de fermeture ou de
redémarrage de réacteurs donc j'invite
chacun d'entre vous à aller sur rémy
peut-être la première fois c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais après ça va
très vite et vous saurez ainsi à chaque
instant quels sont les réacteurs qui
fonctionne et quels sont les réacteurs
qui sont en phase de maintenance pour
diverses raisons mais c'est aussi une
trentaine de secondes je sais que c'est
très court mais
pardon oui merci mesdames et messieurs
les parlementaires en 30 en trente
secondes le président vous a donc dit
que nous avions 25 réacteurs en ce
moment à l'arrêt 10 pour la maintenance
programmés 10 pour des réparations sur
la corrosion sous contrainte et cinq qui
sont en cours de d'analysé d'études
justement lié à nouveau à la corrosion
sous contrainte le calendrier de réponse
est de retour et le suivant nous avons
cinq réacteurs qui sont attendus ce mois
de septembre 5 au mois d'octobre 7 au
mois de novembre 3 en décembre 3 en
janvier et 2 au mois de février tout
ceci évidemment indépendamment des aléas
techniques qui peuvent toujours arriver
sur des process industriels qui sont
complexes je respectais votre en dessous
mais c'est parfait c'est précis merci
beaucoup de choses je vais proposer à
madame la porte de prendre la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur
lévy mes chers collègues je pense qu'il
vous faut reconnaître un réel mérite
dans la gestion de la situation actuelle
en effet malgré le manque de visibilité
dans lequel vous laisse l'exécutif en
prévoyant des dispositions toujours en
vigueur de la loi énergie-climat de 2019
la fermeture de réacteurs mais aussi en
maintenant le dispositif fortement
inéquitable qui est la reine élément
central du simulacre de marché
concurrentielle de l'électricité que
nous impose au droit européen et
véritable poison pour le chiffre
d'affaires d'edf il me semble que nous
serons d'accord pour saluer le travail
des cadres ingénieurs et techniciens
d'edf et a ce mérite j'ajouterai celui
de l'honnêteté de votre démarche celle
de pointer du doigt certaines
incohérences du politique qui
indépendamment des circonstances
particulières tenant à la pandémie à la
crise gazière et aux défauts récemment
découvert sur certains réacteurs met
notre système de production électrique
dans la tension actuelle
mais question iront dans le sens le
premier qui nous occupe aujourd'hui est
de savoir à quel point notre appareil de
production électrique sera capable de
faire face cet hiver tout d'abord les
derniers mois ont été marqués par la
découverte du problème de corrosion sous
contrainte sur certaines tuyauteries de
plusieurs réacteurs qui pour des
exigences de sécurité a considérablement
ralenti leur redémarrage vous avez
abordé cette ce thème mais je voulais
plus précisément pour les années
suivantes le procédé de contrôle par
ultra sons que vous mettez en place
permettra t-il d'éviter de longs arrêts
comme ceux de cette année je voudrais
aussi revenir sur le problème de la
fermeture de fessenheim imposé pour des
motifs purement politique et dont
l'exécutif a dernièrement voulu vous
faire porter une partie de la
responsabilité en invoquant un défaut
d'entretien pendant les dernières années
d'activité de la centrale vous avez à
plusieurs reprises fait savoir que vous
regrettez cette décision qu'on vous a
imposé ma question est double d'une part
comment l'exécutif at il répondu aux
réserves que vous allez poule plus
opposé avant la mise à l'arrêt d'autre
part est ce que vous considérez la perte
de ce moyen de production comme
techniquement irréversible
indépendamment des décisions politiques
à venir
le même questionnement peut être étendue
à d'autres moyens de production
pilotable depuis que vous avez pris vos
fonctions à la tête d'edf près de 8
gigot gigawatts de centrales à charbon
et au fioul en têtard est en france
métropolitaine dans un objectif tout à
fait louable de baisse de la part des
fossiles dans le mix électrique
mais sur la même période aucun réacteur
nucléaire npt et rentrer en service et
le déploiement de gaza était limité les
dernières années ont vu un singulier
déclin de nos sources pilota
d'électricité au profit de sources
intermittentes éolienne et solaire les
gouvernements successifs de la période
ont ils mesuré le risque de cette
orientation pour la stabilité de notre
réseau estimez vous que certaines de ses
centrales thermiques soit techniquement
redémarre à bhl à l'image de celle de
saint-avold dont les salariés ont été
rappelées cet été alors que la fermeture
définitive était acté pour terminer du
côté de la consommation se pose de des
capacités d'effacement quatre experts de
la question affirmé le 15 juillet
dernier dans le monde qu'elles sont
passées entre le début des années 2000
est aujourd'hui de presque 10 liga watts
seulement 3,6 les particuliers s'étant
largement détournée des contrats
effacement tarifaire particulièrement
utile pour l'unité du pic de
consommation
donc oui j'en termine non je suis désolé
la règle est pourtant monsieur président
directeur général on vous a laissé une
minute pour conclure
beaucoup de questions dans la 21
mentions de madame la porte je vais
essayer de répondre factuellement
46 secondes
vous savez combien edf a combattu la
reine sans aucun succès mais vous savez
que nous avons toujours estimé que
mécanisme qui
revient à subventionner nos concurrents
sont contrepartie
était
un mécanisme ne répondant pas aux
besoins que nous avons en électricité je
n'ai pas besoin d'épiloguer en ce qui
concerne l'équipement que nous sommes en
train de construire et qui doit nous
allons que nous allons multiplier nous
allons reconstruire plusieurs bien sûr
il a comme je les dis pour mérite
principal d'éviter d'avoir à tronçonner
des tuyaux qui évidemment site nécessite
d'être reconstruire et ressouder et de
pouvoir faire ce qu'on appelle un examen
non d'esprit dit non destructif donc
nous pensons en effet être en mesure
avec cet équipement d'être plus efficace
dans la gestion des phénomènes de
corrosion sous contrainte merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
pavel brutt et les ficelles
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général vous nous
avez donné des éléments sur la manière
dont vous envisagez que le parc
nucléaire puisse passer l'hiver
on constate sur les outils dont vous
avez parlé kylie a par exemple pour le
deuxième jeudi du mois de janvier qui
est statistiquement une date
particulière pour l'approvisionnement
énergétique
un manque de 8 mégawatts de production
nucléaire est ce que c'est ça auquel
renvoie les réacteurs qui reste
resterait si tout va bien à remettre en
route en février où est ce que cette
autre chose par ailleurs nos voisins
allemands dans les stress tests
énergétique qui le produisent ont un
scénario du pire qui table sur seulement
41 mégawatts de production nucléaire
française qui les impacts e s que vous
aussi vous avez un scénario de ce type
là dans les cartons d'edf et auquel cas
comment ça se traduirait si on était à
ce niveau-là de production nucléaire en
termes de nécessité ce que vous dites
d'effacement ce qu'on dira ici de
coupure de rationnement dans pour
l'ensemble de notre pays et est ce que
en l'espèce il ya bien une priorité qui
est accordée au marché français par le
producteur que les français ont payé
avec leurs impôts qui s'appelle edf vous
payez une situation dans laquelle edf a
aussi une part de responsabilité on ne
peut pas oublier que pendant des années
encore très récemment le retard sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
est certes la responsabilité des
gouvernements mais aussi celle de votre
entreprise qui a beaucoup prioriser le
nucléaire dans ses projets y compris
dans ses projets à l'étranger et vous
avez cité inc les 'points est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que cet
investissement à l'étranger étaient
comme à l'époque votre directeur
financier une mauvaise idée et qu'il
aurait mieux fallu y renoncer et
consacrer cette énergie au développement
des énergies renouvelables et
singulièrement au développement des
renouvelables en france
vous dites qu'on est vous êtes aussi
responsable par exemple du fait que si
on en est aujourd'hui à relancer
certaines centrales au charbon ou à ne
pas fermer celle de cordemais c'est
parce que edf a décidé avec la vie ou
sur demande peut-être du gouvernement
d'enterrer le projet de reconversion du
site qui a seulement dû être relancée
après avoir été une première fois
abandonné est-ce que là il n'y a pas un
défaut de visibilité est ce que c'est
une décision d'edf ou est ce que c'est
une décision que le gouvernement vous a
demandé de prendre pour en revenir sur
la question nucléaire vous nous dites
c'est un point essentiel indispensable
pour atteindre les objectifs de cet
hiver et puis bien au delà les objectifs
climatiques permettez nous d'en douter
la stratégie de relance du nucléaire
elle repose essentiellement sur des
oeufs p r dont aujourd'hui aucun ne
fonctionne correctement dont le seul qui
est en construction en france a dix ans
de retard et hâter près de 20 milliards
d'euros est ce que vraiment mettre tous
nos oeufs à l'avenir sur ce type là
n'est pas créé déjà les conditions de la
pénurie el alia août et de l'explosion
des prix à 6 mai 7 h 30 donc monsieur le
président directeur général
une minute alors pour choisir parmi les
différents thèmes abordés je veux dire
peut-être rapidement que
l'équilibré offre demande il est géré
par rte le président de rte s'exprimer
hier aujourd'hui surtout aujourd'hui je
crois que vous l'avez invités pour cet
après midi donc je voudrais renvoyer
vers lui tout les sujets qui porte sur
les interconnexions au fond aux
frontières et les différents scénarios à
tel ou tel moment de l'année simplement
pour vous dire que nous nous espérons si
les choses se passent normalement
obtenir les la production du parc
nucléaire français à la hauteur de ce
qui a été décidé dans les scénarios que
nous avons préparé partiellement avec
erreur suite étant ces scénarios à
d'autres considérations qui ne qui ne
sont pas les nôtres et que notre
objectif est d'avoir à peu près le même
la même production nucléaire disponibles
pendant l'hiver que celle que nous
avions l'hiver précédent où les choses
se sont bien passées puisque chaque
français a eu l'électricité dont il
avait le besoin à chaque instant
peut-être vous dire un mot sur int
époque je pense qu'il ne fait pas il
était une excellente décision
le programme se déroule c'est bien il a
un petit retard mais qui n'aurait pas de
retard avec le co vide avec le break
site avec l'inflation avec le l'emploi
en grande bretagne où on a énormément de
mal à faire venir des salariés dans les
champs tiers les taux de chômage sont
extrêmement faibles en grande bretagne
donc simplement souligné que le chantier
de l'epr était un chantier qui se
déroule bien merci et puis rappelez que
nous avons deux réacteurs au
fonctionnement à taishan faudrait
peut-être pas les oublier de nombreux
compatriotes de nombreux collègues d'edf
de framatome son parti à taishan pour
faire fonctionner ces réacteurs qui
aujourd'hui tourne normalement merci
mais je présente directeur général alors
nous passons monsieur vigier du groupe
et la
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général nous savons
tous l'énergie nucléaire constitue une
chance pour notre pays d'autant plus
dans le contexte actuel en effet la
hausse des prix de l'énergie est une
source d'inquiétude aujourd'hui majeur
pour tous les français notamment
monsieur le président directeur général
dans nos territoires ruraux plus
généralement la conjoncture que nous
connaissons nous interroge sur la
souveraineté énergétique de notre pays
qui se trouve mise à mal et pour
laquelle il est vital d'agir très
rapidement
justement concernant le nucléaire après
une décennie d'absence totale de vraies
politiques à la matière avec le
lancement d' aucun nouveau projet est
surtout marquée par la fermeture de la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim il a
finalement été annoncé et c'est une
bonne chose en février dernier une
relance du nucléaire or aujourd'hui rien
ne semble avoir avancé et pour autant il
est urgent ans quand on sait que l'on
risque de devoir faire appel à des
sources d'énergie bien plus polluantes
pour répondre en partie aux besoins des
français dans les mois prochains aux c
est vous le savez monsieur le président
directeur général le rôle d'edf est
absolument crucial justement vous pouvez
vous nous dire quelle stratégie
permettrait de faire face aux besoins en
énergie dans les échelles de temps
requises tant du point de vue vous
l'avais dit la rénovation
modernisation
et renouvellement du parc nucléaire que
du développement des autres sources
d'énergie comme les énergies
renouvelables je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur vigier monsieur
président directeur général
annonce merci monsieur le député donc en
effet nous avons activement
contribué à des études que le
gouvernement de l'époque avait commandé
il y a deux ou trois ans d'une part à la
gent s'internationalise l'énergie
d'autre part à rte ici en france de
façon à donner un éclairage sur les
besoins en électricité de notre pays à
terme et comme vous le savez donc rte a
publié à la fin de l'année dernière
certain nombre de scénarios de référence
en s'appuyant notamment parce que pas
que bien sûr s'appuyant notamment sur
les contributions des experts d'edf rte
a ainsi je crois démontré que et
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
avait dit la même chose que le meilleur
mix c'est un
combinaison meilleur mix électrique est
une combinaison d'énergies renouvelables
de nerfs l'hydraulique l'éolien et avec
un fort développement d'éolien en mer
d'ailleurs je salue tous ceux qui ont
contribué à ce que le chantier de
saint-nazaire se déroule bien il a été
terminé dans les temps mais avec un taux
qui peut davance et aujourd'hui les 80
mâ sont érigés et tourne et produisent
pour le réseau électrique
est évidemment de l'énergie solaire qui
se développe un peu lentement dans notre
pays et puis on certaine que certaines
sommes d'énergie nucléaire ceci a
contribué à ce que le président de la
république emmanuel macron lors du
discours de belfort en février de 2022
il ya un peu plus de six mois donne un
cap qu'il s'agit maintenant qu'il va
s'agir maintenant de décliner dans les
textes qui seront présentés devant le
parlement est évidemment qui
s'appliqueront à edf dans sa propre
programmation d'entreprise il est donc
prévu que les réacteurs du parc
nucléaire puisse être prolongé aussi
longtemps que la sûreté le permettra il
est prévu de donner suite à la
proposition que nous avions formulées de
construire
ils centrales nucléaires je dirais dès
que possible et nous avons des équipes
qui travaille très activement sur ce
programme il est prévu d'envisager qu'au
delà de ces six premiers réacteurs nous
allions jusqu'à 14 et puis il est
évidemment prévu une très forte
accélération du renouvelable edf joue en
france et souvent aussi à l'étranger un
rôle absolument majeur dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
c'est une changement d'attitude en
quelque sorte que j'avais donnée lorsque
je suis arrivé en 2015 et tout ceci va
contribuer à un nouvel équilibre du d'un
système électrique en croissance parce
que beaucoup de pompes à chaleur
beaucoup de véhicules électriques
décarbonée parce que nucléaire et
renouvelables et en toute souveraineté
parce que nous n'aurons versant de
dépendance importante à des pays
extérieurs merci beaucoup monsieur de
billets pour le groupe modem
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le prix dans les
villes tout d'abord au nom du groupe
démocrate je tenais à saluer votre
engagement votre haye depuis 2000 14 à
la présidence d'edf ainsi que celui de
tous les agents travailleurs de premier
rang qui je rappelle ont maintenu la
production d'électricité durant le
confinement aujourd'hui nous vivons une
situation inédite si cette audition
avait eu lieu il ya un an les sujets
aurait été différent nous ne rions pas à
parler de l'énergie hors de prix ou de
savoir si nous allions avoir des
coupures de chauffage cet hiver sur ces
deux points les français veulent des
réponses au fil des années la fée
électricité devenu invisible du grand
public et fait partie de notre vie
quotidienne je ne reviendrai pas ici sur
l'augmentation déraisonnable et massive
de l'électricité et la nécessité de
réviser le mode de calcul de
l'électricité indexé sur le gaz ni la
reine qui enrichit certains traders plus
qu il fut dit fut la concurrence éviter
toute coupure d'électricité cet hiver
pour les français telle est notre
objectif premier afin de mieux préparer
les années à venir j'aimerais vous
interroger sur trois points l'enjeu du
personnel disponibles et formés l'enjeu
de la ressources en uranium et l'enjeu
de l'urgence de programmer des ep aires
deuxième génération
en premier lieu comment former et mettre
en place la prochaine génération de
techniciens pour répondre aux besoins de
la filière des prochaines années et
décennies ensuite concernant l'uranium
le kazakhstan l'australie le canada sont
nos principaux pays ressources au vu du
contexte géopolitique qu'elles sont
pays vers lequel nous devons orienter
nos approvisionnements et qu'elles sont
des réserves on années de consommation
d'edf concernant les op r deuxième
génération et leur nécessité cela n'est
pour moi plus un sujet de débat mais un
sujet qui doit être d'action et de
décision
à très court terme produire plus
d'électricité produire localement et
décarbonées anticiper les besoins futurs
notamment ceux liés à la consommation
des mobilités électriques sont des
nécessités en france des territoires
sont déjà largement mobilisés pour
accueillir des oeufs perd 2 je pense
notamment aux six de bugey dans l'ain à
quand des annonces il est urgent d'agir
monsieur le président je vous remercie
merci c'est à vous de choisir merci
enjeux de personnels disponibles et
formés
je crois qu'il faut distinguer les
salariés d'edf et les filières
industrielles qui nous accompagnent
nous avons au sein d'edf comme je les
dis renouveler assez largement au début
des années 2010 le
les compétences rajeunie et nous avons
nous sommes en mesure de traiter ce nom
nous avons besoin dans les filières ce
n'est pas la même chose les chefs
d'entreprises auxquelles je parle en
très grande majorité pour ne pas dire en
totalité ont du mal à recruter nous
manquons d'attractivité dans l'industrie
d'une manière générale certains bassins
d'emploi sont entre guillemets saturé et
donc il y à un véritable souci que nous
essayons de traiter avec différentes
dispositif notamment régionaux locaux
l'éducation nationale et autres j'ai
parlé par exemple de l'université des
métiers du nucléaire tout à l'heure je
n'y reviens pas en ce qui concerne votre
question sur l'uranium nous estimons à
la fois que les stocks que nous avons et
la solidité que nous avons avec eux
les contrats qui ont été passés par nos
collègues doha nos avec différents
fournisseurs d'uranium et quelquefois
par les mines qu'il exploite eux mêmes
que ceux ci nous donne une bonne
garantie de diversité
d'approvisionnement de sécurité sur le
moyen sur le long sur le très long terme
et ce n'est pas aujourd'hui pour le
président d'edf c'est aussi significatif
enfin en ce qui concerne le pr2 je
partagerai ce que ce que ce que vous
avez dit monsieur le député nous
estimons qu'aujourd'hui il est très
important que alors que déjà le chantier
de hinkley paint se termine au niveau de
certaines des compétences nécessaires
sur le chantier au moment où nous avons
besoin de changer de braquet pour
construire les six prochains jeux ps2 il
nous paraît en effet important que tous
les toutes les parties prenantes soit en
bon ordre de marche de façon à ce que ce
programme puisse être lancée et j'inclus
ray évidemment les dispositifs
législatifs réglementaires qui
permettront de lancer ce projet est dans
ces dispositifs législatifs et
réglementaires
évidemment la régulation le financement
le mode de définition des recettes de
ces futurs op r est un sujet majeur qui
reviendra le df vraisemblablement
nationaliser de traiter avec le
gouvernement dans les mois qui viennent
si beaucoup mais mme battistel groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général vous avez je
crois déjà répondu à la première
question qui concernait le respect du
calendrier de maintenance on nous avait
fait part à la fois de l'absence de
marge de manoeuvre que vous avez et puis
assister sur le temps industriels qui
n'est pas le temps politique
donc dans la suite de cette question
j'en avais une deuxième pour faire suite
à la demande du gouvernement
sur la construction de 6 nouveaux
européenne la commission nationale du
débat public a été sollicitée m'a
d'ailleurs auditionné la semaine
dernière pensez vous que la france
aujourd'hui dispose suffisamment de
savoir faire et de moyens humains par
rapport ce que vous nous avez dit en
introduction pour mener à bien ce projet
à la fois dans le calendrier indiqué et
avec un coût maîtrisé je reviendrai sur
la question de la reine chacun ici dans
cette commission c'est combien ce point
mérite
il y a eu le relèvement du plafond de la
reine qui a encore une fois pénaliser
votre entreprise et le gouvernement a
fait supporter à edf une part
significative du coût du bouclier
énergétique pouvez vous nous donner
aujourd'hui un coup actualisée de la
mesure pour l'entreprise et nous voyons
de plus en plus d'exemples
d'énergéticien qui revendent leurs
arènes sur les marchés d'électricité
jusqu'à 10 fois plus cher après avoir
réalisé des opérations pour se
débarrasser de certains clients ce sont
évidemment des manoeuvres qui pénalise
votre entreprise avez-vous des
confirmations que les amendes
qui leur sont octroyés cas évoqués au
madame la ministre hier sont à la
hauteur de l'enjeu et pour finir une
question nous avons aussi une réponse
une réponse de la ministre hier madame
panière une hr sur la sortie du marché
européen de l'électricité qui pour elle
reviendrait à se passer de la solidarité
européenne c'est à dire des importations
d'électricité dont nous avons besoin et
ça c'est peut-être en oubliant
que
ces échanges transfrontaliers
d'électricité étaient bien antérieurs à
la mise en place du marché européen de
l'électricité
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
battistel plusieurs plusieurs questions
en ce qui concerne la maîtrise des six
paires ça fait des années que nous les
préparons nous avons donné à l'état une
proposition très complète il ya bientôt
deux ans et la question de savoir est ce
que nous serons gérer ce programme la
réponse c'est que nous faisons tout pour
le faire sur le plan de les compétences
et de la qualité j'ai lancé le plan
excellent c'était il ya maintenant trois
ans fin 2009 à 2019 le plan excellent
une fois par an c'est en public une
présentation des avancées de ce plan
pour convaincre je crois que les choses
sont en bonne voie ensuite nous aurons
des questions de volume
saurons nous mettre en marche l'ensemble
de ce qu'il faut sur le plan d euros sur
le plan des moyens locaux sur le plan
des moyens nationaux je crois qu'il faut
en effet le planifier il faut
l'organiser et franchement nos collègues
ont été capables de construire certaines
années cinq réacteurs de livrer
certaines années cinq réacteurs il ya
quelques décennies je vois pas pourquoi
on serait pas capable d'ici à 2040 d'en
livrer 6 à condition de bien planifier
bien de l'organiser et peut-être de
faire en sorte que l'action succèdent
rapidement au débat il faut des débats
mais aussi à un moment donné de l'action
sur la reine et l'abus darren alors sur
le chiffre précis sous sous contrôle de
ma mémoire mais qui devrait pas
défaillante au premier ordre nous avons
publié fin juillet dans le cadre de
notre communication financière un
chiffre sur les effets de des vins
térawattheures additionnel la reine qui
ont été décidées pour edf qui dépasse
légèrement les 10 milliards d'euros qui
dépasse légèrement les 10 milliards
d'euros donc ils vont peser sur nos
comptes 2023 en ce qui concerne la
manière abusive dont certains opérateurs
peuvent
se comporter vis-à-vis de cette
électricité très bon marché qu'il aurait
livré par edf
brochet alerté tellement de fois sur
cette situation que finalement je me
réjouis aujourd'hui le gouvernement et
la commission de régulation de l'énergie
s'est saisi du dossier et je crois face
le maire joue pour mettre fin à ces
jeunes merci beaucoup mais madame vers
nous pour le groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général cette
audition intervient à un moment et vous
l'avez rappelé à ces critiques et
suscite légitimement un certain nombre
d'interrogations notamment avec
l'augmentation et l'explosion des prix
mais aussi fait rare le craintes sur
l'approvisionnement électrique en france
surtout ces difficultés mettent en
exergue la difficulté réelle et vous en
avez fait état de la filière du
nucléaire qu'on croyait pourtant
infaillible non par son
désinvestissement comme vous avez pu le
dire ou insinué puisque malgré les
propos qui ont été tenus la fermeture de
fessenheim n'était pas là un marc de
désinvestissements dans le nucléaire
mais vous aviez vous même indiqué que
les investissements pourraient être trop
lourd qu'il y avait trop de défaillances
et qu' il y avait à un moment donné une
nécessité de fermer aussi des réacteurs
qu'on ne pouvait plus prolongée
de plus le désinvestissement n'est pas
une réalité puisque vous l'avez vous
même exposé le plus grand carénage a
déjà décaissé un certain plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros
que dire ensuite des milliards qui
continuent à être investis dans la
centrale de flamanville sans réelles
perspectives quant à une date
d'ouverture
j'en reviens et vous avez eu des propos
pour nous rassurer sur le fait que vous
aviez un plan que nous pouvions
continuer à faire face à la crise
énergétique inédite que nous vivons
aujourd'hui en répondant avec toujours
la même réponse c'est à dire le tout
nucléaire pourtant vous avez fait part
d'un certain nombre d' imprévus auxquels
la fille hier nucléaire n'était
visiblement pas préparés la faillite
industrielle sur flamanville sur les
autres repères à l'étranger mais est
compris la corrosion sous contrainte
nouveau phénomène non anticipés je
voudrais vous
interroger sur un point également que
vous n'avez pas évoquer le réchauffement
climatique puisque les centrales dont
nous prolongeons la durée de vie nous
avons grand peine à prolonger leur durée
de vie doivent être refroidis par des
cours d'eau or nous avons vu avec les
températures caniculaires que nous avons
dû déroger pour pouvoir rejeter de l'eau
plus chaude dans nos fleuves et puis
nous voyons aussi que nous allons avoir
une pénurie en ressources en eau je
voudrais vous interroger comment edf et
anticiper cette phénomène structurel sur
le parc ancien mais également dans la
perspective de nouveaux the p r enfin je
voudrais vous interroger sur les
objectifs de doublement de capacité de
nr installé pour atteindre des 50
gigawatts en 2030 j'ai envie de dire
plutôt que de regretter la fermeture de
fessenheim ne regrettait pas vous là le
retard pris en matière de construction
d'énergies renouvelables enfin sur la
sobriété il a fallu que les faillites de
la filière se démontera nous pour que
vous ayez à vous monsieur le président
directeur général merci je voudrais
d'abord démentir les propos que me que
ma tribu madame les renaissent donc
pardon mais je j'ai je m'inscris en faux
sur certaines des choses que vous me
faites dire on pourra en parler
peut-être séparément ensuite sur les
différents points dont vous avez parlé
je vais dans un instant donné donné la
parole à à cédric lewandowski pour
qu'ils vous parlent de la manière dont
nous anticipons les questions de gestion
d'eau et avant de lui donner la parole
et puisque j'ai je n'ai quelques
secondes donc simplement pour dire que
edf est résolument engagée
dans l'atteinte d'un objectif de 50 que
j'ai même remonté à 60 gigas watts de
nerfs à l'horizon 2030 pour cela il nous
faut la volonté nous l'avons la
compétence nous l'avons les moyens nous
en avons certains mais comme vous le
savez notre bilan est aujourd'hui très
contraint et donc la question se posera
dans les années qui viennent de notre
capacité financière à atteindre cet
objectif qui est absolument majeur pour
le groupe cédric rapide monsieur lennon
ce qui peut-être une trentaine de
secondes là encore vous êtes vraiment
sous contrainte désolé
court terme long terme court terme le
sujet de la gestion de l'eau n'est pas
n'est pas nouveau pour edf heureusement
et donc nous disposons d'un certain
nombre de mécanismes qui nous permettent
de disposer de modification temporaire
d'arrêter pour les rougets lorsque les
fleuves et rivières sont trop chaud
simplement heureusement ils sont
extrêmement rares je tiens simplement
vous dire qu'après un été aussi
exceptionnel que celui que nous avons
vécu nous avons utilisé huit journées
pour le budget huit journées pour
golfech une journée pour saint-alban et
neuf jours pour le tricastin donc nous
disposons de cet appareil heureusement
c'est le court terme le moyen terme et
le long terme vous avez parfaitement
raison la question du réchauffement
climatique et de la gestion de l'eau est
absolument fondamental nous avons
construit un programme spécifique dont
je crois que tous les pouvoirs publics
reconnaissent là à la vertu qui
s'appelle adapte et qui vise à réfléchir
de manière systémique à toutes les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
sur l'eau mais pas que sur l'eau
évidemment sur l'ensemble de nos
centrales vers 6hoo à rendre simplement
hommage à tous ceux qui ont travaillé
depuis 2003 et la canicule puisque là on
parle des rejets mais je note que malgré
l'été difficile que nous avons vécu que
ce soit sur les hommes ou sur les
matériels nous n'avons pas eu d'accident
malgré les canicules bien merci beaucoup
j'ai eu beaucoup de 5 minutes 20 on va
essayer de tenir le timing alors je
monsieur jumelles je crois pour c'est
sur une question courte réponse courte
est le règlement permet cet échange jeux
interactifs feront une question courte
je le président-directeur général avez
vous été un électron libre à l'égard de
l'exécutif pendant votre mandature
je crois en avoir beaucoup fabriquées
des tron
je vais préciser ma question est ce que
l'état les gouvernements le président de
la république dans la détermination
stratégie globale en matière de
politique énergétique dont la politique
de stop and go dans l'élaboration de la
ppe dans le mécanisme de la reine dans
les renoncements européens y compris de
l'europe qui transforme l'énergie en
marchandise est ce que des décisions
prises par l'exécutif ont empaqueté les
finances d'edf ont rendu difficile des
capacités de 2 des fo matière de
renouvellement de savoir faire est ce
que cela est préjudiciable pour la
situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui
seul député vous savez toute entreprise
edf est une entreprise j'en suis le
mandataire social toute entreprise
s'inscrit dans un contexte edf s'inscrit
dans un contexte nous sommes dans un
métier extrêmement régulé il se trouve
que l'état est à la fois le régulateur
et l'actionnaire aujourd'hui à 85 % pour
arrondir de l'entreprise cotée peut être
pas pour longtemps edf et donc le rôle
du mandataire social et de défendre
l'intérêt social de l'entreprise en
s'inscrivant dans un contexte et donc
c'est ce que je fais depuis depuis huit
ans et bien évidemment je défends les
programmes les projets des opinions que
c'est que dégage l'entreprise et dont je
suis le porte parole et le est le
vecteur vis-à-vis d'un état sous toutes
ses différentes formes qui a une
influence absolument majeur sur tous les
sujets dont dont vous avez parlé et cela
fait partie du contexte le contexte va
sans doute changer puisque nous n'aurons
plus de
deux ministres at her représentant les
investisseurs privés au sein du conseil
d'administration puisque eux mêmes
vraisemblablement au moment des
renationalisations
auront disparu nouveau contexte nouveau
mode de fonctionnement vraisemblablement
d'edf dans ce nouveau contexte est donc
simplement pour vous dire que le seul
intérêt social peut-être terminée là
dessus l'intérêt social par définition
s'efface devant l'intérêt général mais
l'intérêt social mérite d'être défendu
et il m'est arrivé de faire valoir
l'intérêt social dès lors que l'intérêt
général et l'intérêt social ne
coïncidait pas tout l'hiver sous
différentes formes et ça a été dans la
quasi totalité des cas dans des
discussions que j'ai eues avec l'état
actionnaire et le ministère des finances
merci de cette réponse elle conforte
l'opinion du groupe communiste de
déposer une commission d' enquête pour
identifier les responsabilités de l'état
sur la situation dans laquelle edf se
trouve aujourd'hui au plan financier au
plan stratégique au plan de ses
fragilités compris je n'évoque pas mais
je pourrais évoquer le rachat de la
branche électrique
la filiale américaine imposés par
l'états alstom après avoir contraint de
s'en débarrasser j'ai une autre question
qui a pris la décision politique
de fermer fessenheim est ce que
fessenheim était en état d'être
prolongée quand cette décision a été
prise
donc simplement pour vous dire qu'à mon
arrivée en 2014
vous posez la question là
les gouvernements avaient mis en place
une délégation interministérielle à la
reconversion du site de fessenheim il ne
l'avait pas fait sur aucun des autres
des 18 autres sites nous avions à
l'époque 19 sites et la loi était
quasiment voter la loi dite de 2015
était quasiment voter qui plafonnait la
production de l'électricité
française est donc de fait la
maintenance courante de fessenheim était
lancée il aurait été contraire aux
dispositions
législatives et réglementaires à la fois
la loi de 2015 et
le décret demandant à préparer la
reconversion du site il aurait été
contraire te préparer à ce moment là les
travaux lourds dit de grand carénage
pour ce site est donc là l'intérêt
général la loi les décrets nous
conduisait inéluctablement vers cette
situation qui a été suivi par votre
serviteur c'est à dire assurer la
maintenance courante terminées les
cycles de production de fessenheim tels
qu'ils étaient prévus pour aller jusqu'à
40 ans mais ne pas préparer puisque le
site devaient fermer à la fois en
application de la loi et en application
du décret ne pas préparer l'extension de
la durée de vie de fessenheim voilà la
situation que j'ai trouvée est appliquée
à mon arrivée très bien merci pour ce
dialogue comme quoi on peut poser
beaucoup de questions en fait en 4
minutes et et ça fonctionne on termine
par madame bassir du groupe hayotte
merci monsieur le président
appuyez prévu
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général vous avez
mentionné l'embauchent de 2000 personnes
mais de combien de personnes faudrait-il
pour répondre aux enjeux de demain
entretenir le parc mener à bien le grand
carénage construit des 6 p r promis par
le gouvernement et concernant les
défauts de corrosion sous contrainte est
ce anormal ou cela résulte-t-il du
fonctionnement normal des unités de
production j'avais d'autres
interrogations similaires à celles de
mes collègues sur l'état du parc
nucléaire et notamment sur la capacité
d'edf de répondre à la demande d'énergie
des français cet hiver aussi permettez
moi de vous poser une question qui sort
un peu de ceux du cas de cette audition
les fournisseurs d'eau à la réunion rue
ney aulas issues des eaux ou encore la
saphir voient leur facture d'électricité
augmenter de 20% soit plusieurs millions
d'euros supplémentaires les
distributeurs d'eau sur les plus gros
consommateurs d'électricité dans l'île
ils subissent deux ils subissent de
plein fouet l'augmentation du prix du
kilowattheure ces entreprises réclament
des actions fortes de l'apport de la
part de l'état notamment un dispositif
spécifique pour les outremers car il
finit ce sont les consommateurs qui
supporteront cette inflation en travers
de leur facture d'eau dans l'hexagone
les industriels ont obtenu du
gouvernement la garantie d'un bouclier
tarifaire limitée à 4% comme pour les
particuliers
la ressource en électricité n'étant pas
d'origine nucléaire à la réunion le
département n'a pas eu droit à cette
aide pensez vous possible de ramener ce
qui serait juste l'augmentation de 20% 1
4% et ainsi permettre de faire baisser
la facture de février 2023 de près de
16% je vous remercie
monsieur le président directeur général
et c'est bon deux sujets très très
différents ce qui concerne le premier
sujet et les recrutements oui pendant
des années nous avons augmenté les
effectifs de 1000 personnes par an de
façon à préparer cette maintenance
lourde que le grand carénage et à la
réaliser dans les délais dans les
conditions et dont les prescriptions
techniques et les prescriptions de
sûreté qui sont qui sont prévus
aujourd'hui nous avons devant nous le
lancement du programme le pr2 la mise en
application du discours de belfort la
mise en application de notre propre
proposition de construire dès que
possible si le p r sur le territoire
métropolitain d'ailleurs en l'occurrence
sur les années qui qui
[Musique]
qui suivent nous avons l'ambition de
recruter environ 2500 à 3000 personnes
chaque année nous recrutons partout en
france et met bien sûr de manière
privilégiée dans les régions les plus
industrielles ou celles dans lesquelles
il y à un grand nombre d'unités
nucléaire comme la normandie le grand
test le centre val de loire l'auvergne
rhône alpes et provence alpes côte
d'azur et puis nous allons nous appuyer
pour aider la filière a recruté ce dont
elle a besoin de son côté sur
l'université des métiers du nucléaire et
sur tout et je rends hommage à tous ceux
qui travaillent aussi sur le thème du
nucléaire dans les régions dans les
rectorats et dans les
l'organisation professionnelle notamment
locales gens rencontrent régulièrement
aux samoa à lyon ou à poitiers par
exemple de façon à rouvrir des
formations spécialisées nucléaire et a
préparé ce grand programme cela dit les
vrais chantiers ne vont pas commencer
maintenant nous avons être dans les
trois quatre cinq prochaines années
concentré sur la préparation de
l'ouverture de ces chantiers parce que
nous ne nous aurons besoin de textes
nous permettant permis de construire
décret d'autorisation de création d'une
installation nucléaire de base nous
permettant de lancer des dix chantiers
donc les prochaines années sont
consacrés à la préparation de ces
chantiers nous estimons aujourd'hui
avoir pris la mesure du sujet et je me
réfère d'ailleurs à ce que bernard
derosier qui disait il qualifiait très
justement de plan marshall ce dont nous
avons besoin pour relancer la
construction de prb oui c'est un terme
que je trouve très très justifiée parce
que nous avons besoin de rendre ce
programme cohérent avec les moyens dont
nous disposerons mais je crois que nous
sommes très conscients de ce que nous
avons à faire et puis il nous reste
quelques secondes pour vous parler de
tarifer et vous savez bien que je vais
vous renvoyer à des décisions du
gouvernement il se trouve que c'est une
coïncidence que je crois la première
ministre madame bornes doit s'exprimer
sur les questions tarifaires dans les
heures qui viennent et je ne peux que
vous renvoyer aux décisions que prendra
le gouvernement sur la manière de ne pas
transposer directement dans les prix sur
le territoire français ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur les marchés de gros
européen merci beaucoup je vais donc
prendre les questions individuelles le
député
on a noté on va continuer à le faire 20
kg était pas tout le monde va pouvoir
l'imposer par contre règles de base à
une minute je coupe fermement et ensuite
monsieur le président directeur général
je vous proposerai une réponse
collective à toutes ces questions qui
vont vous être proposés nous commençons
donc avec madame brégeon
ça marche merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président directeur général
chers collègues ma question concerne la
tenue des planning de maintenance en
partant d'un constat que depuis 2014 nos
moyens de fois où vous avez revu la
durée d 1 disposant de transparence a
augmenté pour prendre l'exemple du cp1
c'est 5 en moyenne par arrêt en 2014 27
si je ne dis pas de bêtises en 2022 donc
première question quelles peuvent être
les problèmes structurels à l'origine de
cette tendance et pour en revenir à la
question du planning actuel et du
passage de l'hiver d'une part quel degré
de confiance dans ses déclarations rémy
tu vous avez est ce que vous êtes bien
aligné avec les scènes sur le planning
de redémarrage et comment est ce que
vous expliquez que hertz anticipe des
dispositifs hic hâtivement plus basse
que edf moins de 50 gigawatts en janvier
et moins de 30 100 gigawatts en novembre
je vous remercie merci monsieur léné
ça y est merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président directeur général
vous nous avez parlé des embauches en
hausse ces dernières années edf et des
difficultés du reste de la filière lors
des journées du medef vous avez déclaré
qu'il n'y avait pas de problème de
compétences et d'expertisé edf mais que
vous manquiez de bras du fait de
l'absence de formation des équipes vous
aviez à cette occasion déploré certaines
incohérences du gouvernement c'est un
constat que je partage pour autant je
souhaiterais un tir et enfin vous
interroger sur l'une des raisons qui me
semble également expliquer les problèmes
de maintenance du parc nucléaire il
s'agit du recours massif à la
sous-traitance lors de la dernière
mandature les députés de la france
insoumise ont déposé à ce sujet une
proposition de loi en 2020 ou dénoncer
ce phénomène qui intervient dans tous
les domaines la maintenance la
radioprotection la logistique la
décontamination l'assainissement ainsi
que la collecte les déchets la
blanchisserie etc les sous traitants du
nucléaire réalise 80% des activités de
maintenance et reçoivent également 80%
des dose annuelle radioactive
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faille renoncer
à la sous traitance pour des questions
de sûreté mais aussi tout simplement de
fonctionnement on voit les difficultés
actuelles voici beaucoup monsieur paco
plus de questions d'accord ensuite
monsieur bothorel
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général le rapport
falk appelle une séparation très claire
des fonctions de maître d'oeuvre de
maître d'ouvragé au sein d'edf
considérez-vous que l'organisation
actuelle répond à cette recommandation
merci
merci madame pintal et
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général vous aviez
dit tout à l'heure que il devrait être
possible de livrer six nouveau ep hertz
d'ici 2040 à condition de bien planifier
bien organiser ma question porte là
dessus en 2020 la cour des comptes
épinglait la dérive financière des opère
en construction est une des causes de
cette dérive s'expliquer en tout cas la
cour des comptes que l'expliqué par un
lancement précipité et une impréparation
les chantiers ont été lancés alors que
les études d'exécution n'était pas
finalisé la cour des comptes relève 10 à
40% des études seulement qui était
finalisé avant le lancement des
chantiers ma question est simple
pourquoi cette précipitation qui a
généré des problèmes techniques que l'on
connaît et pour les six prochains jeux p
r il faudra sans doute avoir fini les
les études avant de lancer les chantiers
merci monsieur potier merci monsieur le
président monsieur lévy puisque vous
êtes un général athor d'électron libre
de question très politique la première
est il nécessaire de déplafonner le la
ressource d'aidé aux dirigeants
d'entreprises de l'état pour avoir des
grands serviteurs comme vous l'avez été
vous-même c'était une attention qui
avait chuté du gouvernement la deuxième
question elle porte sur le marché
européen de l'énergie la tendance
actuelle est demandée en sortir moi je
pense qu'il faut le réformer en
profondeur pour que ça au service de la
transition énergétique et de
l'accessibilité de tous à l'énergie
quelle est votre vision
merci monsieur taupiac
merci monsieur le président monsieur
président directeur général au delà des
causes conjoncture et de la crise
énergétique inédite que nous connaissons
d'autres sont plus structurelles comme
le dérèglement climatique
l'inflation du coût des matières
premières la nécessaire décarbonation
l'impulsion énergétique du pays et
nécessite une anticipation par les
pouvoirs publics or il semble que notre
politique énergétique notamment
nucléaires a fait l'objet de
tergiversations qui participent à la
crise on constate cette année une faible
disponibilité du parc nucléaire due à la
densité du programme du grand carénage
le retard du chantier de l'epr de
flamanville phénomènes de corrosion sous
contrainte observée dans de nombreux
sites
avec pour conséquence une envolée des
prix de gros de l'électricité pour 2023
qui a été multiplié par dix par rapport
à 2022 au regard de ces éléments
considérés vous donc monsieur le
président directeur général qu'il ya une
responsabilité gouvernementale dans la
situation que nous vivons dû à un manque
de planification en matière de politique
énergétique merci beaucoup monsieur
tivoli oui monsieur le président
monsieur le président directeur général
d'edf je ne voudrais pas être dans votre
fauteuil temps je pense que votre
position doit être celle d'un
équilibriste avisé monsieur macro nous
avez orienté vers un abandon progressif
du nucléaire puis la guerre en ukraine
est passée par là et voilà que le
président fait un revirement à 180
degrés comme nous attend t'habituer la
politique européenne fait supporter à
edf une politique commerciale onéreuse
ubuesque et les prix et abonnements payé
par l'usager deviennent insupportables
le nucléaire est l'un des derniers
fleurons du savoir faire français les
errements de la politique macro nist ont
conduit la france à fermer la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim au total douze
centrales nucléaires ont été fermés
depuis 2012 madame borne est alors
ministre de la transition et de la
reconversion énergétique aujourd'hui
premier ministre elle nous affirme le
contraire la centrale de fessenheim
représente l équivalent de 5600
éoliennes plus de la moitié du parc
total face à cette politique
gouvernementale qui ressemble à une
farce comment allez-vous vous accommoder
de ski et une incompétence d'état que
l'on cherche à faire supporter aux
français en les menaçant de coupures
électriques et quelle sera la part d'edf
dans l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat
des français monsieur brics
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général monsieur des
vies alors que la crise énergétique est
au coeur de tous les débats se pose
nécessairement la question du parc
nucléaire en france en tant que députée
du calvados j'ai pu visiter en 2018 la
centrale nucléaire de flamanville sur la
presqu'île du cotentin dans la manche
les deux réacteurs en service produisent
actuellement l'équivalent de plus de la
moitié de la consommation électrique
annuelle de la région normandie edf a
été autorisé à ajouter un troisième
réacteur de type e pers la construction
de cet ep ère a débuté en 2007 et devait
s'achever en 2012 après un peu plus de
dix ans de retard je me permets de vous
demander si vous pouviez apporter des
éclairages aux français quant à l'état
d'avancement de la construction et la
date de mise en service du réacteur
flamanville 3 et comment expliquer de
tels retards
merci merci madame simonet
première question quelle est monsieur le
président directeur général l'impact du
récent tremblement de terre de l'est de
la france sur le site de bure
d'enfouissement des déchets deuxième
question d'extension de halak à la hague
de retraitement des déchets nucléaires
est contestée comme vous le savez la
meilleure réponse ne serait-elle pas de
cesser de produire des déchets
nucléaires que l'on sait comment traiter
est-ce que edf d'ailleurs travail le
scénario 100% renouvelable donc sans
nucléaire le président de la république
dans son discours de belfort a freiné
les ambitions françaises de
développement de l'éolien terrestre en
repoussant l'objectif de 2030 à 2050
quelle est la position d'edf sur ce
recul risque-t-il de freiner les
ambitions du groupe sur cette filière et
dernière question l'état a décidé de
relever fortement le plafond de
rémunération des dirigeants
d'entreprises publiques qui est fixé à
450 milles euros annuels en vue de
recruter le prochain pdg d'edf dans le
contexte actuel de forte hausse des prix
qui paie son pouvoir d'achat des
français une telle décision ne porterait
pas atteinte à l'image d'edf si beaucoup
monsieur d'escaut zai
merci monsieur le président ce jeu
président-directeur général juste une
question très rapide et très technique
vous avez déjà dans vos interventions
évoqué les scénarios sur les prochains
hivers j'aurais juste que vous nous
fassiez until focus sur l'hiver en
2023/2024 qui va venir très vite est ce
qu'il y a une préparation particulière
sur la nous avait bien évoqué les plans
qui avait pour passer cet hiver-là qu'en
est il du prochain ce qui va venir ces
dates à court terme
merci beaucoup monsieur martinez
merci
merci monsieur le président directeur
général nous avons appris dans la presse
que le 12 septembre dernier une
cargaison d'uranium russe a été
déchargée au port de dunkerque
cette cargaison aurait eu pour
destination une usine de fabrication de
combustible nucléaire en allemagne usine
géré par framatome filière d'edf j'ai
donc deux questions très précises à vous
poser première question est ce que vous
confirmer ces informations
qui pour l'instant sont apparus
uniquement dans la presse suisse et à
des enquêtes de journalistes et deuxième
question tout le monde comprendra la
contradiction flagrante entre ces
événements et la politique étrangère du
gouvernement vis-à-vis de la russie mais
la question que je vous pose c'est quel
et quels sont les contrats en cours les
contrats à venir avec rosa tome
l'entreprise publique russe en charge du
nucléaire est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire voilà quels sont les procès des
prochaines activités communes et s'il
est prévu de les faire évoluer merci
merci madame ranger
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général la fermeture
de fessenheim imposé pour des motifs
purement politique et non pas de défaut
d'entretien comme l'exécutif a tenté de
vous en faire porter en partie la
responsabilité a eu des conséquences
lourdes sur la production d'énergie
aussi nous souhaitons connaître la
réaction de l'exécutif face aux réserves
que vous avez pu lui opposer avant la
mise à l'arrêt de la centrale et
considérez vous la perte de ce moyen de
production comme techniquement
irréversible indépendamment des
décisions politiques à venir merci
merci monsieur rodwell
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général lors de son
discours de belfort le 10 février
dernier le président de la république a
annoncé la construction de 6 nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires et la musique est
la mise à l'étude de huit autres ceux ci
s'ajouteront aux 50 6 réacteurs de notre
parc nucléaire existant de votre
intervention vous avez évoqué le temps
industriels
ma question porte sur la gestion de long
terme de notre parc quels sont les
principaux défis auxquels est confrontée
edf dans l'exploitation des réacteurs
existants et nouveaux sur les 40
prochaines années
monsieur alexandre
monsieur lévy dans différents rapports
on peut lire qu'il y a des problèmes de
corrosion et de fissures dans les
tuyauteries cela interroge grandement
sur la sûreté car certains réacteurs
sont mis à l'arrêt à cause de cela
monsieur lévy pouvez-vous nous assurer
que toutes les conditions de surêté de
sûreté sont suffisantes à ce jour
pouvez-vous nous assurer que ces
problèmes de corrosion ne réapparaîtront
plus dans les décennies à venir sur les
tuyauteries réparer ainsi que sur les
nouvelles constructions et enfin au vu
des problèmes de sûreté et que le p r de
flamanville a coûté déjà 20 milliards et
ne fonctionne toujours pas est il
pertinent de prévoir la construction de
nouveaux apn quelle mesure vous semble
pertinente pour éviter un tel naufrage
merci messieurs jumelles
président vous connaissez mon engagement
pour faire de poignet un projet
exemplaire socialement et
environnementalement en termes
d'aménagement du territoire de formation
nous on inaugure in écoles de
robinetterie dans quelque temps
peut-être serez-vous à nos côtés mais
pour sa foi edf fort en edf de plein
exercice à edf recapitalisée la loi de
nationalisation
rime-t-elle avec le retour des reculs
saucissonnage d'edf est donc le la
fragilisation de drs que hercule est
toujours d'actualité
messieurs tard elle
oui vous personne n'a évoqué ce matin
les smr dont pourtant le président de la
république avait parlé est ce que ça
veut dire que comme nous le pensons
c'est plutôt une chimère ou en tout cas
quelque chose qui n'est pas près d'être
fonctionnel avant au mieux les années
2040 est donc totalement inopérant face
à l'urgence climatique que nous devons
faire face à laquelle nous devons faire
face la des délais les années qui
viennent et même des dés à présent
ensuite je voudrais vous reposer la
question de ma collègue battistel à
laquelle vous n'avez pas répondu
comment se fait-il qu'on assimile
toujours l'interconnexion technique et
le marché alors que ce sont deux choses
différentes et qu'on peut très bien
avoir des interconnexions et des
échanges d'énergie en dehors du marché
comme c'était le cas d'ailleurs avant
que le marché existe et enfin à propos
des prix on voit la volatilité des prix
ne pensez vous pas qu'il serait sain de
revenir à un système dans lequel le prix
de l'électricité est fondée uniquement
sur les coûts réels de production
déconnecté de tout mécanisme de marché
et merci monsieur lui pardon c'est oui
monsieur lopez ligori
avis
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général votre mandat
à la tête d'edf fini en marche 2023
après deux mandats sa tête donc et il
apparaît que vous n'allez pas être
renouvelé vous aviez critiqué la
politique du gouvernement lors de
l'université d'été du medef en mettant
en lumière le manque de formation des
équipes dans le secteur et vous avez
accusé l'état d'avoir orienté edf vers
des fermetures supplémentaires de
centrales nucléaires dans un contexte de
pénurie c'est contre l'ordre ont empêché
edf de se projeter et d'investir mettant
en danger notre indépendance énergétique
emmanuel pro macron à juger vos propos
inacceptables et a assuré que le
gouvernement n'avait jamais donné de
telles directives
face à ces discours contradictoires les
français ont le droit de connaître la
vérité pensez vous que votre non
renouvellement est dû à votre liberté de
ton et à vos accusations et pensez vous
également qu'un changement de direction
à la tête d'edf en pleine crise
énergétique risque de déstabiliser
affirme anne est un peu monsieur roger
tam
ont trouvé oui comme amara bon on a
droit de poser des questions rhétoriques
je me posais une save et vous puisque on
l'entend ici beaucoup évoqué la
variation éventuelle des positions du
gouvernement ou de certains hommes
politiques je vais vous citer une
responsable politique assez connus vous
a laissé deviner qui sait
faut-il en finir avec l'énergie
nucléaire réponse oui il s'agit d'un
objectif qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
expliqué t-elle la décrivant comme
énormément dangereuse cette intervention
date d'il ya plus de dix ans elle a
conclu en disant cette sortie serait
positive et limiterait les dangers pour
le monde mais ne peut se faire que
progressivement et doit passer par là
l'investissement massif dans la
recherche concernant les nouvelles
énergies quelle est donc cette
responsable politique au cas où vous
l'auriez pas la question je vous la
donne monsieur et madame marine le pen
merci beaucoup après cette série de
questions tout le monde a pu s'exprimer
alors alors madame pochon et après
madame région après on arrête on est
d'accord
allez-y très très rapidement merci
monsieur le président sur la
construction
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général je souhaiterais vous
parlez du tricastin on le voit dans le
débat public actuel tricastin est l'une
des ces centrales qui nous pose la
question du niveau de risque auquel nous
sommes prêts à consentir pour garantir
l'approvisionnement énergétique de notre
pays en d'autres mots est ce que notre
sécurité énergétique vous d'autres
risques sécuritaires car la centrale du
tricastin au delà des risques il y à la
corrosion au manque d'eau aux
conséquences du changement climatique ou
la non déclaration d'incident ou
d'accident il ya une information
judiciaire qui a été ouverte comme
nombre d'autres se situe sur une zone
sismique voici ma question monsieur le
directeur quel est le niveau de risque
acceptable à votre avis et comment
s'assurer que les nouveaux et p r puisse
y faire face comme il est envisagé
d'implanter au tricastin sur zone
sismique
merci madame aux gens
merci monsieur le président très
rapidement sur le programme 6 p r
pourquoi selon vous il était nécessaire
d'aller sur des oeufs pr2 est ce qu'il
n'aurait pas pu être préférable de
repartir sur un design perrin en
bénéficiant éventuellement du retour
d'expérience directe de flat trois
caisses qui sous caisse qui a sous-tendu
ce choix merci
bien après cette longue série de
questions mais le président-directeur
général je vous donner la parole pour un
temps illimité beaucoup le temps que
vous le souhaitez et merci par avance
pour vos réponses
merci vous c'est bon vous m'entendez
peut-être essayer de tenter de regrouper
certaines et certaines des questions de
bronze ce qui concerne notre
organisation et le retour d'expérience
par rapport à la construction de
flamanville
rapport que j'ai que j'ai commandé à
jean martin folz et public il avec
trentaine de pages il est assez facile à
lire il est
accessible et il explique ce qui s'est
passé est en effet madame pitt elle l'a
dit une impréparation qui a conduit à de
multiples dérives dans laquelle edf a
une responsabilité majeure
les
la question sur la mise en service
monsieur weeks nous en train de terminer
les réparations des soudures qu'il faut
refaire puisque l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire
nous a demandé de refaire des soudures
c'est un programme qui est assez long
qui est en train de se terminer qui a
été perturbée d'ailleurs là aussi par le
cos vide qui est en train de se terminer
qui doit nous amener à ce que la le
chargement du combustible avec après
autorisation de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui aura donc validé
l'ensemble du du réacteur y compris
après des périodes d'essai finaux qui
doivent être faites en début d'année
prochaine et donc tout ceci nous amène à
ce que le charge le chargement du
combustible soit autorisée par
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
au mois de juin 2023 donc dans neuf mois
les parmi les différentes
enseignement parmi les différents
enseignements de flamanville oui une
certaine impréparation une d une
conception détaillée ce qu'on appelle le
design détaillée du réacteur qui
n'étaient pas achevés lorsqu'on a
commencé à construire c'était
probablement pas une bonne idée et aussi
des questions d'organisation et donc de
ce point de vue là je réponds notamment
monsieur bothorel oui nous avons d'ores
et déjà mis en place à l'intérieur du
groupe edf une séparation claire entre
la maîtrise d'oeuvre et la maîtrise
d'ouvragé avec des responsables et des
équipes qui sont claires tout ceci étant
de plus supervisé par le contrôle des
grands projets là aussi une des
recommandations du rapport de jean
martin folz qui a été mise en place dans
une autre direction d'edf donc en toute
indépendance et qui vient à chaque revue
ce que je fais à peu près tous les
trimestres peut-être même plus souvent
que ça une revue des grands programmes
comme
loïc les poètes et les experts du
contrôle des grands projets viennent
donner leur propre opinion sur ce qui
m'a été présentée de façon à
confirmer ou pas a confirmé que ce qui a
été présenté au management d'edf reflète
bien la réalité les risques et les
performances donc tout ceci est en cours
d'organisation
dans le discours de belfort le président
de la république a aussi estimé
nécessaire que soit mise en place et je
crois que ça va être fait très
rapidement que soit mise en place une
structure de l'état pour piloter edf
piloter la filière dans le cadre du
programme d'aidé eu peur d'eux on
l'appelle la délégation
interministérielle aux nouveaux
nucléaire enfin c'est comme ça que moi
je l'appelle c'est pas moi qui vais la
la nommer ces d'état qui je crois très
rapidement va mettre en place cette
délégation donc nous aurons une
structure de commandement une structure
de pilotage de supervision qui sera très
différente et qui je l'espère aura
correctement pris en compte les
enseignements
le retour d'expérience que nous que nous
tirons de
2,2 de la construction évidemment
difficile de flamanville 3 en ce qui
concerne ce que j'ai dit sur le manque
de bras je me suis expliqué là-dessus
tout à l'heure le recours à la
sous-traitance et bien évidemment
indispensable nous ne lisons nous ne
vivons pas dans un monde unique et nous
avons besoin de sous traitants qui
travaillent pour nous mais qui travaille
aussi pour d'autres donneurs d'ordre ne
sommes pas le seul donneur d'ordre du
nucléaire en france vous voyez bien quoi
je fais allusion nous l'industrie du
nucléaire s'inspire des meilleures
pratiques d'autres industries
il est évident que nous avons tous à
apprendre de ce qui se passe dans
l'industrie mondiale de la haute
technologie et que nous nous restreindre
aux compétences et au moyen de ce que
serait le seul parc nucléaire français
serait une perte absolument
incommensurable et d'expérience et
d'efficacité et donc il est tout à fait
normal qu'une grande partie de nos
activités soient sous traité à des gens
qui travaillent sur d'autres projets
industriels nucléaires et aussi sur
d'autres projets industriels non
nucléaire donc
je crois que c'est comme ça que
fonctionne la plupart des grands projets
dans le monde le nucléaire civil n'a pas
de raison d'y déroger je voulais vous
parler aussi de réformes du marché
européen un point qui a été abordé par
plusieurs d'entre vous monsieur tavel
monsieur potier et d'autre oui le marché
européen aujourd'hui donne l'impression
d'être un petit peu au bout du modèle
qui a été mise en place il ya 20 ou 25
ans et on voit bien que même si il ya eu
un certain déni de la part
des instances communautaires au tout
début de cette crise après après
l'invasion de l'ukraine et bien ce qui
s'est passé cet été sur les prix
l'effet de ces prix sur les
consommateurs les opinions publiques les
représentants que vous dans le monde de
politique vous êtes de cette émotion on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui dans une
certaine urgence les instances
communautaires sont en train de se
préoccuper de savoir s'il faut pas
procéder à des changements radicaux du
modèle européen et donc
les ministres se sont réunis la semaine
dernière mise de l'énergie vont se
réunir à nouveau le 30 septembre de
mémoire entre temps de nombreuses
conversations de nombreuses études sont
en cours pour voir comment on peut avoir
un marché européen qui fonctionne mieux
alors il fonctionne évidemment à travers
ces interconnexions qui rendent un
service absolument majeur évidemment à
la fluidité du système à l'efficacité du
système et on peut démontrer sans mal
que les interconnexions permettent de
faire baisser les prix pour la
collectivité européenne mais le tout
marché si je puis dire aujourd'hui on en
voit on en voit les limites à travers le
le caractère assez spéculatifs des prix
qui sont atteints dans certaines
conditions de marchés puisqu'il
reflèterait le fait que nous aurions des
interruptions quasiment permanente cet
hiver ce qui n'est pas du tout prévu et
puis il ya le phénomène de
fonctionnement un peu systématique du
prix observée sur le marché avec
le prix du gaz ce fameux couplage va
doit-on aller vers un découplage gaz et
électricité qui le le souhait de la
france d'autres pays manifestement ne ne
se range pas à cette idée nous avons le
problème du découplage du prix du gaz
domestique par rapport au prix du gaz
mondiales comme vous le savez espagnol
et portugais ont obtenu une dérogation
cette dérogation doit-elle être étendue
et puis poi points qui pour le pour moi
même est le plus important comment faire
en sorte que le marché qui est par
définition à marcher déquilibre de court
terme et ça je crois que personne ne
remet en cause qu'il faut comparer les
différents moyens de production
d'électricité sur le court terme comment
faire en sorte que ce système appuyé
malgré tout donc sur un marché au moins
de court terme donnent des signaux
d'investissement à long terme or les
seuls signaux d'investissement à long
terme qui sont aujourd'hui possibles
sont des dérogations au régime général
qui passe par une
procédure extrêmement longue et pénible
est sourcilleuse de la commission
européenne sur les aides d'état sur la
manière dont les différents acteurs se
compare les uns les autres sur le fait
qu'il pourrait y avoir un risque de
création de position dominante et donc
aujourd'hui le marché n'est pas organisé
le pardon le système n'est pas organisé
pour qu'au-delà du marché on puisse
vraiment donner des signaux
d'investissement à long terme et
d'ailleurs on va voir comment la notre
pays va gérer la construction des six
pr2 dans un système qui doit
nécessairement donner des signaux
d'investissement à long terme nos amis
britanniques l'ont fait ils ont fait
voter une loi c'est sur la base d'actifs
régulés sétois existe elle est en
service elle va certainement s'appliquer
sur le projet
saïdou elle sait si ce projet est
finalement décidée par les parties
prenantes et nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui le même dispositif en europe
et donc cette réforme elle prendra sans
doute du temps elle prendra sans doute
la forme d'une révision peut être assez
profonde des directives qui ont créé le
marché européen tel qu'il fonctionne
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai évidemment
un sujet absolument majeur qu'est qui
est devant nous donc je voulais juste
passer quelques minutes à le commenter
je voulais dire un mot des smr est dû et
du hms et du renouvelable une fois de
plus de df est très engagé dans les
énergies renouvelables si nous sommes
capables d'avoir des parts de marché
importantes en france grâce au plan
solaire que j'ai lancé il ya cinq ans
c'est parce que nous faisons beaucoup de
solaire à l'étranger et quand on compare
le
les projets que nous sommes capables
collectivement d'assumer vis-à-vis de
des parties prenantes sur le territoire
français nous nous battons pour obtenir
3 5 ou ou 20 mégawatts de solaire à tel
ou tel endroit et bien heureusement que
nous avons pour faire baisser les coûts
la capacité aux etats-unis au
moyen-orient de construire des fermes
solaires qui monte jusqu'à 1500
mégawatts projet qui serait sans doute
inacceptable en france mais qui nous
permet d'apprendre et de faire baisser
les coûts pour faire bénéficier les
français de ce qui se passe à l'étranger
puisque il faut le dire malheureusement
nous sommes tout petit petit petit dans
ce qui se fait aujourd'hui dans le
domaine du solaire en france ce qui
concerne les les smr les petits réacteur
modulaire nous avons lancé il ya
maintenant trois ans avec une conférence
de presse commune un engagement de la
filière nucléaire française et ceux ci
incluent edf mais aussi le cea d'aval
groupe technicatome et est également
notre filiale framatome un engagement a
lancé un premier concept de smr français
ce concept qui s'appelle new world est
en train d'être affinés il va bénéficier
de financements au titre d'une part de
france relance et d'autre part de france
2030 de telle sorte que dans quelques
années nous ayons la possibilité de
construire à côté des grands réacteurs
de type p rpr de nos à vos besoins des
réacteurs modulaire qui pourront nous
aider dans un cadre français par exemple
la proximité de
l'industrie on peut penser à la
sidérurgie qui auront des besoins très
ponctuelle sur à proximité des grandes
des grands lieux de production
sidérurgique en en france et puis bien
sûr aussi pour des marchés à à
l'étranger je voudrais répondre toujours
sur le sur le nucléaire que bien
évidemment
la sûreté reste le point essentiel qui
guide l'ensemble de nos décisions donc
quand j'entends les uns et les autres
remettre en cause les décisions de
sûreté que nous prenons je ne peux que
m'élever contre ce préjugé je crois
malvenue d'autant plus que nous
bénéficiions en france avec l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire d'une autorité très
experte très indépendante et qui valide
la totalité des décisions que nous
prenons donc je pense que tordre le cou
à cette légende en matière de sûreté
fait partie de mes responsabilités en ce
qui concerne
les questions qui sont liées à l'avenir
changement de président je n'ai pas
beaucoup de choses a ajouté je vous
renverrai simplement aux communiqués qui
est sorti début juillet qui parle de la
nécessité de lancer la recherche d'un
successeur qui a été peu décision qui a
été prise d'un commun accord entre le
gouvernement et moi-même parce qu'il me
paraît personnellement logique que le
gouvernement puisse travailler avec un
président d'edf ayant du temps devant
lui et que changer le président d'edf en
mars 2000 23 parce que c'est la date de
la limite d'âge et que ces date de mon
anniversaire
n'est pas vraiment pertinent quand on
pense à l'ensemble des enjeux d'edf est
donc le gouvernement et moi-même nous
avons souhaité que soit mise en place un
procès du processus pour que rapidement
un président d'edf soient nommés qui est
le temps devant lui de construire dans
l'entreprise et avec son actionnaire et
son régulateur l'état la réponse aux
enjeux qui sont et aux défis qui sont
devant nous voilà ce que je voulais dire
pour répondre à la quasi totalité des
questions n'ont peut-être aussi des
questions sur les sanctions eh bien oui
nous avons aujourd'hui depuis la guerre
en ukraine une série de sanctions qui
ont été mises en oeuvre pour
sanctionner c'est bien le mot l'invasion
de l'ukraine par la russie bien
évidemment nous appliquons la totalité
de ces sanctions en étroite coordination
avec le gouvernement
français nous avons en effet des
contrats nous avons en effet comme
monsieur s'il vous plaît nous avons en
effet comme bien d'autres pays dans le
monde des contrats avec l'industrie
nucléaire russe l'industrie nucléaire
civile russe ne fait pas aujourd'hui
l'objet de sanctions si elle fait
l'objet de sanctions nous appliquerons
des sanctions s'il ne fait pas l'objet
de sanctions nous continuerons à
appliquer les contrats auxquels nous
nous sommes engagés c'est extrêmement
simple ce n'est pas edf qui en clans
décide et donc je vous renvoie vers les
sanctions européennes qui à mon avis ont
été pris à juste titre contre la guerre
que la russie est allé créer sur le
territoire ukrainien il y avait quelques
questions techniques sur
les questions de piscine les questions
de préparation de l'hiver les questions
d'audit sur la manière dont nous gérons
nos arrêts de tranche le les questions
de la manière dont le parc prépare ses
activités à long terme monsieur rodwell
je vais renvoyer ces questions vers vers
cédric levandowski si vous le voulez
bien sur les demandes de ski
monsieur le président alors
on regarde effectivement des quelques
questions complémentaires
madame région vous avez posé la question
de la tenue des planning de maintenance
qui est effectivement une question
importante
oui nous avons des marges de progrès sur
le sujet il n'y a pas de doute et nous y
travaillons alors la question première
c'est pourquoi est ce que le niveau de
maintenance s'est effectivement dégradée
en tout cas la durée des arrêts s'est
prolongée mais la raison au fond elle
est assez simple nous avons beaucoup
plus de travaux à mener sur l'ensemble
du parc et il y aura de toute façon un
avant et un après fukushima
avec c'est normal et c'est tout à fait
légitime des réglementations qui ont
évolué et en général dans le sens du
durcissement
parallèlement mais c'est un effet
purement démographique
c'est le moment ce durcissement où il a
fallu renouveler beaucoup de nos
compétences vous le savez du fait de
départs à la retraite massifs et autant
sur le plan quantitatif nous avons pu
renouveler ses compétences et nous
sommes très heureux d'accueillir
beaucoup de jeunes générations et de
jeunes compétences mais il ya une
différence entre compétences et
expériences et cette différence on la
voit aussi très nettement par définition
avant d'être au meilleur niveau de
maintenance des anciens il va falloir
quelques années pour que nous nouvelle
génération soit au meilleur niveau alors
pour répondre à ces difficultés là très
clairement deux initiatives très fortes
la première prise par le directeur du
parc nucléaire étienne dutheil qui est
d'ailleurs derrière moi et qui a lancé
un grand programme qui s'appelle start
2025 qui est un programme participatif
c'est à dire que ce sont les salariés de
l'ensemble de la direction du parc
nucléaire qui se sont exprimés sur tous
les points d'amélioration potentielle
qui pouvait être
utile et qui font l'objet d'un vaste
programme qui vise à améliorer le niveau
des compétences alors ça passe notamment
par un sujet qui est la ré
internalisation nous devons ré
internaliser un certain nombre de
compétences c'est une évidence adapter
notre organisation peut être au
programme industriel tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire plus d'équipés
sur les arrêts et puis évidemment aussi
donner peut-être un peu plus
d'initiatives au site on est souvent
caricaturée pour un système très
militaire ça des vertus de grandes
vertus mais il faut aussi que
l'initiative soit possible sur le
terrain parallèlement le président d'edf
a demandé suite à une concertation avec
le gouvernement nous dit qui a été
réalisé par les sociétés indépendantes
tout au long des six premiers mois c'est
audit a été rendue publique à la demande
de la ministre qui était devant vous
hier ir soir il est donc évidemment
disponible et c'est un audit qui lui
aussi apportent des compléments au
programme start 2025 que je viens
d'évoquer et nous en espérons beaucoup
est ce que tout ceci se fait
en parfaite liaison avec l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire bien sûr et
heureusement tout ceci a été présenté à
l'autorité de sûreté et je crois
apprécié sur la question des séismes
puisqu'il ya eu deux questions qui sont
venus sur le sujet c'est pas du tout un
un tabou malheureusement je ne peux pas
répondre sur les conséquences du
tremblement de terre récents sur ben hur
puisque comme vous le savez bur ne
relève pas de l'autorité d'edf mais un
organisme indépendant qui s'appelle
l'andra donc sincèrement je n'ai pas les
informations concernant ses conséquences
sur la question du tricastin la question
sismique est une question d'une très
très grande complexité il n'y a pas de
doute elle fait l'objet de travaux très
nombreux cpe df qui définit les les
mesures le principe se dit du sms le
séisme majorité de sûreté qui est
convenu et arrêtés par l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire après des travaux
notamment peu n'est menée par l'irsn
est-ce que la vallée du rhône connaît
sur cette question là une actualité oui
le séisme du teil il y a quelques années
vous en souvenez trois ans nous conduit
à travailler mais d'abord les
scientifiques les géologues et bien sûr
lire et saine et l'asn sur les
redéfinition autour de ces sms c'est à
dire les dimensionnements possible en
tout cas aujourd'hui évidemment toutes
nos centrales tout nos réacteurs sont
parfaitement conformes vous l'imaginez
bien aux séismes majorité de sûreté qui
prend beaucoup de beaucoup de marge et
c'est heureux mais
nous saurons regarder aussi en face les
conséquences des travaux menés par les
géologues sur le séisme du theil sur la
question de l'avenir
plusieurs plusieurs sujets nous avons
récemment donné notre vision d année
prochaine pour la production de l'année
2023 nous anticipons 300 à 330
térawattheures de production et par
rapport à la question du passage de
l'hiver
23-24 b nous ferons les mêmes travaux
que ce que nous avons produit pour le
passage 22 23 c'est à dire veiller à
faire en sorte qu'on ait le maximum de
réacteurs disponibles à ce moment là ce
qui est le travail quotidien constant de
tous les opérateurs du nucléaire depuis
toujours la nouveauté vous l'avez bien
compris c'est l'apparition de cette
crise corrosion sous contrainte qui
durcit le phénomène sinon nous serions
évidemment beaucoup plus confortable sur
l'année 2024 nous anticipons une
production de 315 à 345 térawattheures
ce n'est pas encore
exceptionnel en termes de production
c'est simplement la marque du fait que
la crise de la corrosion sous contrainte
durera bien trois ans le temps de mener
l'ensemble des travaux et des
réparations qui sont attendus c'est à
dire sur les années 2000 22 2023/2024
alors sur la préparation de nos équipes
à l'arrivée de nouveaux réacteurs
d'abord le travail a commencé sur sur
flamanville 3 depuis bien longtemps fait
des années que plusieurs opérateurs et
quand je dis plusieurs c'est près de 500
travail à s'entraîner sur le mode de
fonctionnement des eps c'est un vecteur
très très particulier très différent des
réacteurs existants aujourd'hui
évidemment nous bénéficions du retour
d'expérience de nos amis et d'olkiluoto
et de et de tai shan et les échanges
sont extrêmement nombreux dans la
filière donc nous nous préparons par des
circuits de formation que
vous connaissez qui sont tout à fait
tout à fait classique et puis par
ailleurs nous adjoindre on a toute cette
préparation classique le grand sujet que
nous avons juste effleuré
tout à l'heure celui de l'adaptation
réchauffement climatique qui vu de nous
sur le plan systémique à la date
d'arrivée des repères donc dans les
années 30 et 40 évidemment ce sera un
facteur tout à fait dit mentionnant et
devra faire aussi l'objet de travaux
préparatoires a fait avec l'ensemble de
nos collaborateurs
voilà ce que je crois pouvoir a ajouté
monsieur le président merci beaucoup
est-ce que vous souhaitez rajouter que
c'est bon dites moi
très bien les écouter il me reste à vous
remercier monsieur le président
directeur général d'avoir pris le temps
de venir répondre à nos questions pour
la qualité aussi de vos réponses merci à
toutes vos équipes et à tous les agents
edf bien évidemment merci chers
collègues je vais suspendre et puis nous
allons procéder au dépouillement sur la
domination que nous avons auditionné
tout à leur suspension